von Malotki, aber heute bin ich nicht allein im Studio, denn es ist der Mittwoch im Monat, an dem traditionellerweise das Chaos Radio Offreds stattfindet. Das heißt der CCC. Das Thema bestimmt. Das ist heute Biometrie. Wir stecken hier noch kurz unsere ganzen diversen Geräte ein, melden uns dann gleich und geben erst mal eine kleine Einführung ins Thema, weil es ist sehr, sehr wichtig und wie immer oder fast immer sehr, sehr unbekannt. So, musikalisch haben wir uns ja schon mal wieder festgelegt. Ein bisschen elektronisch, macht aber nichts. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, traditionellerweise, wie immer, am wieviel letzten Montag? Mittwoch mein ich?
Am allerletzten.
Am allerletzten, was ich doch gemeint hab.
Außer die letzten zwei Mal.
Außer die letzten zwei Mal. Wir sind zuviert heute im Studio. Wir haben den Harald dabei, den Peter und den Starbucks, wobei wir sagen müssen, dass Peter jetzt nicht traditionelles, traditionelles sag ich schon zum dritten Mal, das ist mein Lieblingswort, Chaos Computer Club Mitglied ist, sondern Dozent im Bereich Informatik an der HU, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht erzählt hab. Hab ich nicht. Thema heute Abend, ein wichtiges Thema. Normalerweise ist der CCC Vorreiter, was solche Sachen anbelangt. Diesmal auch. Aber so langsam kommen die anderen Pferde nach. Deswegen muss man noch mal aufpassen. Es geht um Biometrie. Ihr habt vielleicht mitbekommen, so langsam werden sie alle wach. Die Europäische Union gibt ja immer so ein paar Gesetzchen vor, denen wir dann alle folgen müssen. Und die überlegen sich momentan ganz viel. Die sind sehr kreativ in Brüssel. Und das, was da jetzt vorgelegt werden wird, das heißt, biometrische Merkmale in Pessen sollen verankert werden. Solche Sachen wie Fingerabdrücke zum Beispiel. Aber bevor wir da zu weit gehen, wollten wir erstmal einsteigen grundsätzlich, was Biometrie überhaupt alles umfasst. Weil das Wort mit B habe ich heute bei uns auch in der Redaktion festgestellt. Da wusste jeder Dritte nicht, was mit anzufangen. Die sagen, Biometrie ist das, wenn ich was an den Knochen habe oder so. Deswegen, das ist nicht so einfach.
Ja, Biometrie, eine genaue Definition davon, wie sie im Buche steht, kann ich nicht geben. Aber es geht eben prinzipiell darum, dass Daten, die mit dem Körper oder Körpermerkmalen befasst sind, in die Ausweisdokumente mit aufgenommen werden. Konkret heißt, geht es also hier um ein digitales Foto, wo dann also versucht wird, eine Gesichtserkennung zu machen oder auch Fingerabdrücke. Andere Merkmale, die biometrisch sind, sind sicherlich noch die Iris. Man kann also von einem Auge, von der Iris, entsprechend ein Foto machen und hier versuchen, Menschen eindeutig zu identifizieren. Was ist also der Sinn dessen, was man da macht? Und die ganze Diskussion, die kam auf. Wie immer, wir wissen ja, dass die Welt seit dem 11. September 2001 eine andere Welt ist und dass es so viel gefährlicher ist, und dass wir seit neuesten Terroristen haben, die gab es ja früher nie und nirgendwo. Und deswegen schreien jetzt sämtliche Sicherheitsinstitutionen, insbesondere eben die Innenminister der entsprechenden Länder danach, hier Ausweise sicherer zu machen, die Länder sicherer zu machen. Und auf dieser Schiene oder in diesem Kurs ist auch die Biometrie in Ausweisdokumenten vorgesehen.
Also vielleicht mal ganz kurz. Biometrie setzt sich aus dem Wort Bios für Leben und Metrik für Vermessen zusammen. Also heißt im Endeffekt so viel wie Vermessen des Lebens bzw. Vermessen von lebenden Personen und wird hauptsächlich zur Identifikation von Personen hier eingesetzt.
Total vermessen. Total vermessen. Gut, also so war die Grundsatzdefinition für alle, die vielleicht noch nie von dem Begriff gehört haben. Nun habt ihr vorhin auch gesagt, als wir über das Thema gesprochen haben, direkt in Klammern dahinter gesetzt, als wir gesagt haben, was ist das, das ist bei der ganzen Sache, so schön sich das anhört, sowas wie eingebaute Fehler gibt.
Ja, das ist richtig. Wir haben beim Messen von Fingerabdrücken, beim Ausmessen der Iris immer ein Problem, dass wir das nicht immer identisch reproduzieren können. Das heißt, dass eine Messung immer zu einer anderen verschieden ist. Das hat ganz verschiedene Gründe. Das kann dann den Umweltbedingungen, unter denen wir messen, liegen. Das kann dann den Menschen liegen, ob er seinen Daumen leicht schräg auf den Sensor legt oder gerade. Das kann aber auch an der Sensorik selber liegen, dass sie älter wird, dass sie einfach nicht mehr so gut ist. Und das führt halt dazu, dass automatisch eingebautes ein Fehler in dieses elektrisches Thema ist.
Ist das nicht sowas, wenn ich jetzt wahrscheinlich der Typ wäre, der das Ding an die verschiedenen Staaten verkaufen will, ich möchte gerne Geld machen, dann würde ich ja sagen, ja, das sind vernachlässigbare Fehler, Toleranzen, oder?
Also noch bis vor wenigen Jahren stand irgendwie immer auf den Hochlandsprospekten 100 Prozent Sicherheit. Also hat halt wirklich jeder Hersteller behauptet, dass er irgendwie gar keine Fehlerraten hat. Inzwischen geben sie es schon langsam zu, dass ihre Systeme halt irgendwie nur zu 99, 9 oder 95 Prozent funktionieren, also die einzelnen Fehlerraten in dem Bereich liegen. Und ja, also es hat sich halt hauptsächlich daher ergeben, dass halt inzwischen einige Feldtests gemacht wurden und sich einfach ausgestellt hat, dass die Systeme halt 100 Prozent nicht haben und dass sie es auch nie erreichen werden. Das ist halt einfach der Grundgedanke bei der Biometrie, dass es sowas nicht gibt. Und daher ist es eigentlich auch nicht geeignet, um halt in Personaldokumenten zu benutzen, um halt Leute zu identifizieren dran.
Und ist das Ganze jetzt irgendwie schon so weit fortgeschritten, dass sich das alles nicht mehr aufhalten lässt? Oder warum wird das jetzt einfach so gemacht, obwohl es offensichtlich nicht reif ist?
Also es gibt Vorreiter von dieser Sicherheitstechnologie, wenn man sie mal so bezeichnen möchte, in Anführungszeichen sind wie so häufig die USA. Im Folge des 11. September wurden eben hier auch die Leute hellhörig, die schon immer gerne irgendwo diese Biometrie gehabt hätten. Also natürlich die Branchenvertreter, diejenigen, die das Equipment verkaufen möchten, die Wissenschaftler, die in den entsprechenden Gebieten forschen, die sehen das natürlich auch gern irgendwo mal im großen Maßstab eingesetzt. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich die, wie soll ich sagen, die Kontrollfreaks, also diejenigen, die gerne den Bürger absolut überall überwacht haben und von jedem Fingerabdruck auf jeder Glasscheibe sofort wissen wollen, wer diese Glasscheibe jemals angefasst hat und so weiter. Also das Szenario, das wir aus Science-Fiction-Filmen kennen, das gerne umgesetzt haben. Die haben diese Gelegenheit genutzt, wie auch viele andere Leute mit Interessen die Gelegenheit genutzt haben, die Bürgerrechte hier auszuhöhlen und das eben einzufordern. Und die USA haben beschlossen, dass ab einem bestimmten Stichtatum kein ausländischer Bürger mehr ins Land darf, das einen Ausweis nicht irgendwelche biometrischen Daten enthält. Beziehungsweise, wenn diese Daten im Ausweis nicht vorhanden sind, dann werden die eben in den USA noch nach erfasst. Das ist das sogenannte US-Visit-Programm nennt sich das. Da muss man dann eben ein Foto von sich machen und einen Fingerabdruck abgeben bei der Einreise. Zwei. Zwei Fingerabdrücke machen die Zeigefinger jeweils. Die hier erfasst werden bei der Einreise. Und durch diesen Druck, den die USA damit erzeugen, auf andere Länder, hat das Ganze international übergeschlagen. Und hier in Europa haben eben jüngst, zwar vor eineinhalb, zwei Wochen, haben sich die Innenminister von fünf EU-Staaten getroffen, darunter eben auch unser Bundesinnenminister. Und haben dort sozusagen beschlossen, dass sie als diese fünf Länder den Fingerabdruck in digitaler Form, also das biometrische Merkmal des Fingerabdrucks in zukünftige Ausweise integrieren wollen. Und jetzt diesen Montag hatten wir die Entscheidung, dass tatsächlich EU-weit eben angenommen wird, dieser Vorschlag der fünf Länder, diesen Fingerabdruck aufzunehmen.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass nicht nur die Amerikaner da Vorreiter sind, sondern gerade in Europa, Deutschland einer der führenden und vorantreibenden Staaten ist. Und zwar irgendwie gerade der Innenminister. Und da kann man sich halt irgendwie überlegen, warum das so ist. Aber wenn man halt mal guckt, wo die ganzen Biometriefirmen herkommen, dann sieht man schon eindeutig, dass Deutschland da relativ gut vertreten ist. Und das kann man halt vermuten, dass der Innenminister da halt irgendwo, naja, wie auch immer.
Na gut, der Innenminister ist nicht der Wirtschaftsminister, der hier die einheimische Wirtschaft stärken will.
Aber die beiden sollen sich kennen.
Ja, richtig, die beiden sollen sich kennen. Die sollen öfter mal zusammen an einem Tisch sitzen. Und darüber hinaus ist es halt auch so, dass Otto Schili doch einen, ich denke, das kann man gemeinhin als akzeptiert nehmen, eine relativ konservative, strikte Innenpolitik führt. Und da sind schon immer die Freunde von Überwachung beheimatet gewesen. Und die Biometrie- und Ausweisdokumenten, wie wir im Laufe der Sendung eben ansprechen werden, ist ganz deutlich dazu geeignet, zu einer sehr viel flächendeckenden Überwachung der Bürger verwendet zu werden, als wir das bisher kennen.
Nun ist die Entscheidung ja irgendwie schon im Grunde gefallen, dass da nie jemand groß gejauhlt wegen Privatsphäre und Ähnlichem, also außer dem CCC jetzt?
Es gibt den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Peter Schar heißt der, der immer wieder und in wie soll ich sagen wöchentlichen monatlichen Rhythmus klagt der an, dass dieses System also ein super Gau für den Datenschutz ist. Dass das in keinster Art und Weise gemacht werden dürfte, wenn man irgendwie Datenschutzrichtlinien eben anliegen würde, aber der hat halt keinen tatsächlichen Einfluss. Der gibt Statements ab und der bemüht sich, aber der hat halt keine Wirkungskraft auf die Exekutive oder Legislative. Der kann halt nur sagen, naja, das ist nicht schön, mir gefällt das nicht. Aus Datenschützersicht ist das nicht angenehm. Oder es ist ein Chaos, aber interessierend tut dann dieses Statement letztendlich wieder niemand.
Das Problem dabei ist auch hauptsächlich, dass die Entscheidungen eigentlich auf europäischer Ebene getroffen werden. Das heißt, die deutschen Gremien da kaum noch Mitsprachrecht haben, außer natürlich Innenminister und sowas, die halt das massiv auch forciert in Europa. Aber die Gesetze werden halt in Europa getroffen und werden dann halt irgendwie nur runtergebrochen auf die jeweiligen nationalen Legislativen.
Und eben nicht mal im Europaparlament. Wenn jetzt ein demokratisches Gremium auf europäischer Ebene darüber entscheiden würde, dann würde man das ja noch irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen legitimieren können. Aber es ist also hier die Regierungsvertreter der europäischen Regierungen, also rein die Exekutive, nicht die Legislative, trifft hier solche Entscheidungen.
Aber du hast ja auch hier so ein kleines Büchlein mitgebracht, was man so als die Essenz dieser ganzen Geschichte bezeichnen könnte, was die Politiker sich dann wahrscheinlich auch durchlesen müssen, auf Englisch, wo es um die Begrifflichkeiten geht, was hinter Biometrie steckt und so weiter. Ich habe ja nur mal reingeschaut und bin dann kurz auf Toilette gegangen, aus anderen Gründen, aber es war halt extrem schwer zu verstehen. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil das ist ja auch das Problem, dass eben halt solche Leute, die das nicht vertreten, die haben halt keine Lobby, weil die Menschen nicht wissen, was mit Biobritrie alles kommen könnte, weil keine Ahnung davon hat, was es überhaupt heißt. Und die Politiker haben es erst recht nicht. Die nicken das doch wahrscheinlich nur abgestoßen von denen, die es haben wollen, weil sie für sich was versprechen, wie zum Beispiel der Schili.
Genau, also vielleicht wollen wir erstmal irgendwie da ansetzen und ein bisschen erklären, was denn Biometrie, also beziehungsweise welche Systeme es gibt und wie die funktionieren. Also erstmal biometrische Systeme kann man grob in zwei Klassen unterteilen. Das ist einmal die aktiven Merkmale, also verhaltensbasiert. Das sind hauptsächlich Handschrift, Stimme oder Typdynamik, also Sachen, wo man aktiv irgendwas machen muss. Und die passiven Merkmale, die physiologischen, sowas wie Fingerabdruck, Gesicht Iris, also die eigentlich, die für solche Anwendungen überhaupt in Frage kommen, weil würde sich keiner hinstellen und dann irgendwie dem Computer irgendwas erzählen, um erkannt zu werden oder seine Unterschrift dauernd leisten. Also jedenfalls nicht, wenn es schnell geht, musst du an Grenzen wofür es ja hier eingesetzt werden soll. Genau.
Wie wird das mal ausgedruckt? Analoges hat er.
Ich kann auch einfach irgendwie so erzählen, ohne es abzulesen. Ist wahrscheinlich günstiger. Also die drei Merkmale, die hier zur Disposition stehen, sind eigentlich die Gesichtserkennung, der Fingerabdruck und die Iriserkennung. Wobei man erstens sagen muss, dass laut deutschen Gesetz, irgendwie kommen wir nachher auch nochmal drauf, die Kombination nicht zulässig ist, jedenfalls derzeit nicht. Also es darf halt nur ein Merkmal eingesetzt werden. Und zweitens steht im Gesetz auch drin, dass die Iris nicht dazuzählt, weil es wird explizit von Gesichtsmerkmalen geredet und die Experten sind sich halt irgendwie einig, dass die Iris nicht als Gesichtsmerkmal durchgeht.
Oh Gott, das ist ja fast philosophisch. Hat sich irgendjemand diese Beschränkungen aufgrund von irgendwelchen intelligenten Sachen ausgedacht oder ist das einfach nur so passiert? Also ich meine, was hat das für einen Hintergrund mit diesem zum Beispiel nur einen Merkmal?
Das war der Schnellschuss, irgendwie, Autokatalog 1. Also nach dem 11. September haben sie irgendwie alle ganz schnell, wir brauchen jetzt unbedingt Gesetze dagegen, weil wir müssen sowas wieder verhindern und haben sich wahrscheinlich mal zwei Minuten hingesetzt, alles aufgeschrieben und das dann einfach so durchgeprügelt. Weil es gab ja irgendwie keine Widerrede, also die Gesetze sind ja praktisch durchgewunken worden im Eiltempo, das war ja unglaublich für irgendwie Deutsche.
Ja, und das ist ja das Furchtbare, dass hier die Politik als Resultat auf den 11. September wie in den USA, wie in Europa, wie in Deutschland einfach total sämtliche Rationalität abgeschaltet hat und man ja nur dem Wahlvolk demonstrieren musste, dass man aktionsfähig ist. Man muss Aktionsfähigkeit demonstrieren, man muss zeigen, die Politiker tun etwas, ob das dann irgendwie sinnvoll ist oder ob es in irgendeiner Art und Weise die Sicherheit der Bürger oder des Landes erhöht. Das interessiert ja niemanden. Bild-Zeitung kann dann wieder schreiben, es wurde etwas getan, da wurde ein Gesetz geschaffen, was auch immer.
Ja, außerdem, ich mein, die setzen natürlich damit auch gerne mal Sachen durch. Also unabhängig davon, dass man irgendwie sehr aktionistisch daherkommt. Sie haben was durchgesetzt, was einige Leute vielleicht haben wollten und sie haben es halt unter dem Deckmantel dieser terroristischen Bedrohung getan. Und dann ist es erst mal da. Und was man da sonst noch mitmachen kann, ist ja teilweise ganz schön für den einen oder anderen.
Ja, und das merkt man ja auch an den Gesetzen, also wie die zustande gekommen sind. Das Terrorismusbekämpfungsgesetz, auf das wir uns jetzt bezogen haben, ist ein Artikelgesetz, in dem also eine ganze Latte von verschiedenen Gesetzen geändert wird. Und das ist natürlich ganz schwierig gewesen in dieser Zeit, ich selber sehr aktiv da miterlebt habe, im Bürgerrechtszirkeln, dann zu schauen, wie sich diese Gesetzesänderungen, die ja nur als Gesetzesänderungen dokumentiert sind, dann tatsächlich umsetzen in den Gesetzen. Und da wurden ganz viele Sachen geändert, das Ausländerrecht, die Passgesetze, das Personalausweisgesetz, das Sicherheitsüberprüfungsgesetz und und und.
Also das Terrorismusbekämpfungsgesetz hat explizit 21 Gesetze bzw. Rechtsvorschriften geändert oder neu erlassen. Also es ist halt irgendwie nicht mal was nebenbei, sondern halt wirklich massive Eingriffe, wie zum Beispiel ins Personalausweisgesetz und sowas.
Okay, aber zu diesen Techniken zurück ist das denn da alles ausgereift? Also wenn wir uns jetzt nur auf Gesicht, Iris und Daumen und so weiter beziehen, was wird da jetzt von wirklich kommen? Also wenn Iris rausfällt, können sie es ja gerne nehmen und irgendwie zum Daumen dazupacken. Werde ich jetzt irgendwie meinen neuen Ausweis kriegen und muss da irgendwie so ein Iris-Scan machen lassen von einem Typen, der...
Also rausfallen tun sie nach der Gesetzeslage, nach der derzeitigen Gesetzeslage. Also was halt irgendwie damals aus dem Autokatalog in Gesetze gegossen wurde, sagt halt, dass sie das nicht machen dürfen. Das ist aber halt irgendwie kein Garant dafür, dass sie es nicht irgendwann tun werden. Man muss jetzt einfach das Gesetz nochmal ändern. Und das steht eigentlich jetzt an, weil zumindest sind diese explizite Trennung, dass man halt nur ein Merkmal nehmen kann, das fällt raus. Weil Gesicht und Finger ist einfach jetzt durch in Europa. Und deswegen muss sie das Gesetz eh ändern. Und dann werden sie wahrscheinlich auch nochmal explizit Iris reinschreiben. Und weiß der Geier was noch alles.
Und die Techniken sind auch wirklich ausgereift? Also gibt es da das System? Ist alles da?
Alles toll ist da gar nicht. Die Systeme haben natürlich jeweils ihre eigenen Schwierigkeiten. Also kann sein, dass bestimmte Menge von Leuten in Europa Merkmale wie das Fingerbild gar nicht so ausgeprägt haben, dass man es messen kann zum Beispiel. Die Gesichtserkennung hat ein ganz großes Problem mit wechselnden Umwelteinflüssen. Das heißt, wenn ich also ein Bild aufnehme und das dann versuche, diesen Referenzdatensatz mit dem aktuellen Datensatz zu vergleichen und das ist unter anderem Beleuchtungsbedingungen entstanden, dann kann der Vergleich viel schlagen zum Beispiel.
Also ein ganz interessanter Teil war aus dem BioFace. Das war eine Studie vom BSI damals.
Also BSI, vielleicht muss man an der Stelle noch erläutern. Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Genau, die haben im Auftrag des Bundesministeriums des Innern, das BMI, diese BioFace Studie in Auftrag gegeben. Die wurde an der BKA, Bundeskriminalniederlassung, durchgeführt und hat teilweise Fehlerraten von 95%. Also gut, das ist inzwischen wieder eine Weile her, hat sich was getan, aber da sieht man mal, was diese Systeme leisten bzw. nicht leisten.
Und die Schwierigkeit ist bei den Systemen, die haben sozusagen eine Anpassung, muss man anpassen. Das heißt, bestimmte Sensoren, bestimmte Software und bestimmten Datenbanken zusammenpacken. Und dann kann man schauen, ob man die optimiert. Diese Zusammenstellung. Aber was passiert ist, wenn man dann eine andere Datenbank drunter tut oder einen Sensor austauscht, dass diese ganzen Informationen oder Erwartungen bezüglich der Fehlerraten hinfällig sind.
Das heißt aber wahrscheinlich nicht, dass sie jetzt so schlau sind, direkt einen weltweiten Standard zu entwickeln. Beziehungsweise, wenn sie den entwickeln, kaufen wir wieder irgendwas, was bei den Amis patentiert ist oder irgendwie so?
Na, das ist schon ein bisschen besser. Also es ist nicht ganz so schlimm. Es gibt hier, da haben wir später auch noch ein ganzes Kapitel in dieser Sendung darüber, die sogenannte ICHO oder auch ICAO genannt, die International Civil Aviation Organization, die also hier diese Standards festlegt. Und es ist also schon so, dass in diesen Standards berücksichtigt wird, dass also nicht Lösungen eines einzelnen Herstellers bevorzugt werden, sondern dass also Standards festgelegt werden, die interoperabel sind, dass man auch auf Patente aufpasst. Das heißt, lange Zeit ist die ICHO zum Beispiel davon ausgegangen, dass man das Iris-Merkmal nicht verwenden kann, weil eben hier Patentprobleme bestehen. Und erst nachdem der Patentinhaber sich dazu bereit erklärt hat, das unter günstigen Bedingungen oder unter festgelegten Bedingungen zu lizenzieren, konnte also dieses Iris-Merkmal offiziell in die Empfehlungen dieser Organisation mit aufgenommen werden. Also hier, auf dieser Ebene versucht man schon irgendwo was Sinnvolles zu tun in diesen internationalen Gremien.
Ich tippe trotzdem mal, ich möchte dann später zitiert werden, darauf, dass wenn das irgendwann mal eingeführt wird, wie einen spontanen Anstieg von Bindehautentzündung in der Bevölkerung haben, weil ja jeder den gleichen Augenstuppel benutzen muss. Da wird wieder keiner dran decken, wird nicht desinfiziert, zack, ganzes Flugzeug. Bindehautentzündung darf nicht in die USA einreisen, weil Bindehautentzündung ist ja eine Seuche. Oder so. Gut, ähm, ja.
Damit wirst du wohl nicht zitiert werden.
Was?
Ich wette drum, ich wette drum.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, ne? Wahrscheinlich werde ich eingesperrt werden, weil es von mir ein Komplot dann gewesen ist, rückblickend. Okay, äh, Gesicht ihres Daumen. Gut, das hätten wir, ähm, abgehakt. Oder sind wir technisch irgendwie noch für...
Man kann ja beliebig in die Tiefe gehen, aber ich glaube, das ist...
Vielleicht doch nochmal zu Fehlerraten aktuellen Studien. Peter, hast du da Zahlen?
Ja, Zahlen hab ich momentan nicht. Also jedenfalls keine jetzt vorliegen. Das auswendig zu wissen, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Aber das, was wir sagen können, ist, dass wir bestimmte Fehlerraten einfach haben. Wir hatten ja schon davon gesprochen, dass da Fehler eingebaut sind insgesamt. Und es gibt zwei Fehler, die sich gegenseitig bedingen. Das ist einer, die False Acceptance Rate. Das heißt also, wenn Leute sich sozusagen autentifizieren und werden, obwohl sie zugelassen sind, abgewiesen?
Die False Acceptance Rate sind die Leute, die angenommen wurden, obwohl sie nicht zugelassen sind.
Genau, und die False Rejection Rate ist das Gegenteil davon. Und die bedingen sich. Das heißt also, wenn ich die False Rejection Rate ganz klein mache, ist die False Rejection Rate ganz hoch. Und wenn ich das dann addiere, habe ich natürlich einen ziemlich großen Fehler. Und man muss halt schon gucken, wie man diese Fehler zum Ausgleich bringt. Oder man sagt halt, okay, ich will ein besonders sicheres Biometriesystem haben, also die False Acceptance Rate ist ganz klein. Dann muss ich aber damit rechnen, dass Leute, die zwar berechtigt sind, sehr oft abgewiesen werden.
Also im Grunde so wie Spamfilter, ich hab mal ein Spamfilter eingestellt. Und wenn ich den Hard einstelle, dann habe ich vielleicht Pech und einer von meinen Freunden, eine Mail von meinem Kumpel rausstelle ich auch in den Mülleimer. Und wenn ich es ganz locker mache, habe ich dauernd eine gute Analogie.
Das ist eine gute Analogie.
Also vielleicht mal noch ein paar Zahlen. Und wie die Biofinger war das, glaube ich, die haben, also sie rechnen halt mit einer False Acceptance Rate von 1% und einer False Reduction Rate von 10%. Das heißt, wenn man sich das mal verdeutlicht, dass jeder Hundertste praktisch unerlaubt dann die Grenze passieren kann, bzw. jeder Zehnte normale Bürger praktisch Probleme hat, weil er unerkannt, also weil er unerlaubt irgendwie jemand anderes ähnlich sieht. Also der Fingerabdruck jetzt in dem Fall. Das sind halt einfach Zahlen, die sind indiskutabel. Richtig.
Selbst wenn man hier ein Promille hat, ein Promille der Gesamtbevölkerung des Landes oder der Welt, ein Promille der Reisenden an einem Flughafen, an einem Tag, das sind immer noch verdammt viele Menschen.
Ja, und für die muss man natürlich Prozeduren entwickeln. Also wenn man so eine Forze Rejection Rate hat, die sehr hoch ist, die werden natürlich dann abgewiesen, müssen aus der Schlange raus. Und für die muss man ja auch irgendeinen Weg haben, dass sie dann trotzdem einreisen können, also wenn sie eine Berechtigung haben.
Nein, das passiert ihnen dann jedes Mal. Also das ist dann irgendwie deutlich schon diskriminierend, weil sie werden nicht einmal abgewiesen, sondern sie werden einfach jedes Mal ausgewumpt und müssen jedes Mal extra checken, jedes Mal nackt ausziehen und durch irgendwelche Scanner laufen. Also das ist eigentlich irgendwie ein echtes Problem und das wird auch noch bis jetzt noch nicht diskutiert. Also es gibt weder irgendwelche diese Backup-Verfahren, sind irgendwie noch nicht diskutiert worden.
Also das Backup-Verfahren wäre, dass irgendwie ein zweites Verfahren anspringt, für den Fall, dass das erste Verfahren irgendwie falsch läuft.
Oder halt dann manueller Abgleich mit den Kontrollbeamten, Grenzkontrollbeamten wieder.
Hört man dann nur so den Gummihandschuh schnappen und der Mann sagt manueller Abgleich, dann weiß man schon. Herrlich. Und das jedes Mal.
Also du willst einfach unfallen. Jetzt mag es ja noch lustig sein, aber dir kann natürlich auch passieren, dass du zufährweise einem gesuchten Verbrecher ähnlich siehst als deine Fingerabdrücke. Das heißt, du wirst dann nicht jedes Mal ausgewunken, sondern du wirst dann einmal nach Kuba abgeschoben und...
Es gab ja tatsächlich schon solche Fälle, wo es Missverständnisse gab und Leute dann auch einen Tag im Gefängnis waren. Deswegen in Untersuchungshaft. Weil sie halt gerade ihrem Fingerbild sehr ähnlich war wie jemand anderem. Aufgrund dieser Toleranzen, die man da einstellt, dann kann das halt dazu kommen, dass halt nicht eine herausgefischt wird, sondern dass es dann halt viele gibt, die dieses Merkmal haben.
Und wenn das dann halt erst mal massiv eingesetzt wird, dann kann es auch schnell passieren, dass das dann irgendwie hunderte, tausende Leute betrifft. Und dann gibt es halt einfach ein echtes Problem.
So, ihr habt vielleicht ungefähr eine Vorstellung davon gewonnen, wie lustig es heute Abend noch werden kann. Und deswegen hoffen wir auch, dass ihr bis 1 Uhr dabei seid. Wir werden auch gleich ein bisschen mit euch darüber reden, was ihr denn von diesem Thema haltet. Biometrie, die große Überschrift heute Abend im Chaosradio. Wir haben es 22.30 Uhr. Machen deswegen jetzt erst mal ein Häppchen Nachrichten und kümmern uns darum, dass ihr auch in allen anderen Sachen korrekt informiert seid.
Wenn Fritz Info halten sehen, dann 100 2, 6.
Ähm, das Wetter? Nachts bleibt es meist trocken. Später kann sich Nebel bilden. Wer Lust drauf hat, die Temperaturen sinken auf 8 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es anfangs neblig, trüb mit ein bisschen Regen. Später kommt zwischendurch die Sonne raus. Die Temperaturen steigen dann auf 12 bis 14 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Ich kann auch nicht mehr Platz machen.
Gleich die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Im Streit um die neue EU-Kommission hat das Europaparlament den Machtkampf gewonnen. Der künftige Präsident Baruse zog noch vor der Abstimmung sein komplettes Team zurück. Viele Europaparlamentarier waren mit mehreren der aufgestellten Kommissare nicht einverstanden, heißt es. In Afghanistan sind offenbar Gefangene von US-Soldaten noch brutaler gefoltert worden als im Irak. Das berichtet das ARD-Politmagazin Kontraste. Ehemalige Gefangene schildern dort die sexuellen Misshandlungen durch US-Soldaten. Missbrauch und Gewaltexzesse seien demnach an der Tagesordnung gewesen. In Deutschland hat die Zahl der illegal kopierten Filme weiter zugenommen. Das geht aus einer sogenannten Brenner Studie der Filmförderungsanstalt hervor. Demnach wurden von Januar bis Juni mit 25 Millionen gebrannten DVDs bereits mehr Filme kopiert als im gesamten Jahr 2003. Die Ergebnisse der Fußball-Bundesliga. Stuttgart unterlegt Bremen 1 zu 2. Nürnberg verliert gegen Schalke 0 zu 2. Mainz schlägt Rostock 3 zu 1. Hamburg besiegt Freiburg 4 zu 0. Leverkusen schlägt Bielefeld 3 zu 2. Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft bestreitet am 9. Juni 2006 in München. Das Eröffnungsspiel der Weltmeisterschaft. Das legte der Fußball-Weltverband am Abend in Frankfurter Main fest. Der erste Gegner wird am 9. Dezember 2005 in Leipzig ausgelost. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit einer Nachtbaustelle. Meldung betreffen die Autobahn 100. Nein, 111. Fährt doch Autobahn-Zuginger Hamburg. 3 Guranienburg Richtung Berlin-Charlottenburg zwischen Weidmanns-Luster-Damm und Kurt-Schumacher-Damm ist die Autobahnfolge sperrt bis morgens um 5. Ansonsten wünschen wir eine gute Fahrt.
Denn Fritz und die Modern Music School Berlin kommen in eure Klasse und machen Spezialunterricht im Fach 3. Musik. Mit den Fritz Soundgarden Moderatoren und Musikexperten Paul van Dyck, Jakob Kranz, Oli Massif, Andre Langenfeld und Radio-Fritze Stefan Michmer. Dazu die Modern Music School Berlin mit professionellem Musikequipment. Erfahrt zur Abwechslung mal etwas über Musik, die euch wirklich interessiert und beginnt selbst Musik zu machen. Gewinnt eine Unterrichtsstunde 3. Musik. Alles, was ihr dazu braucht, findet ihr unter Fritz T und im Radio.
Ja, wir waren kurz versucht auf Sofa zu gehen und Sachen zu bauen, haben es aber gelassen, weil wir wussten, wir mussten die Sendung ja noch bestreiten und wir haben zwar schon viel gesagt, aber zweieinhalb Stunden sind es noch im Chaos Radio heute Abend auf Fritz. Wir sind zu viert im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club vertreten, der Harald und Starbuck. Peter ist Dozent an der HU und mein Name Malotky. Thema heute Abend ist Biometrie. Haben wir schon mal kurz eingeleitet. Biometrische Merkmale sollen ja jetzt demnächst auch in Pässen manifestiert sein und in Ausweisen dann irgendwann auch. Das heißt Fingerabdrücke stehen da zum Beispiel zur Wahl oder sowas wie Iris-Scan oder Fußabdrücke für diejenigen, die etwas größere Pässe haben möchten. Das gehört alles zum Biometrie dazu, weil der Körper wird vermessen.
Kann man den Fußgeruch vermessen?
Zum Beispiel. So ein olfaktorischer Check. Haben Sie Ihren Hund dabei? Nein, habe ich nicht. Gut, aber es gibt natürlich Menschen, die müssen sich damit beschäftigen, das Ganze politisch zu bearbeiten in Brüssel, weil das wird auf EU-Ebene entschieden, dass solche Pässe jetzt auch vielleicht kommen sollen. Und wir haben jemand angerufen, der ganz nah dran ist, nämlich Andreas Dietl, EU Affairs Director von EDRI. So, ich habe die Abkürzung kurz gekonnt und dann war sie auch schon wieder weg, Peter.
Ja, das ist also European Digital Rights und das ist eine Vereinigung von Bürgerrechtsgruppen, kritischen Informatikgruppen, netzpolitischen Gruppen in ganz Europa. Sind 17 Vereinigungen beteiligt in elf europäischen Ländern und Andreas, der in Brüssel sitzt, ist unser Watchdog, was dort vor Ort passiert.
Name ist Andreas. Was genau machst du da? Also was heißt, du sitzt in Brüssel, das hört sich immer toll an, dann sagen sofort alle, achso, du sitzt in Brüssel. Aber was heißt das genau, was machst du?
Das meiste von dem, was ich mache, da wir ja Netzpolitik betreiben, könnte ich auch woanders machen. Ich verbringe meine Tage auch wie die meisten anderen Leute am Computer. Aber ein ganz wichtiger Teil meiner Arbeit ist eben auch, dass ich zu den EU-Institutionen hingehe, zum EU-Parlament vor allem, da mit Leuten rede, Kontakte pflege und versuche, Dinge in Erfahrung zu bringen und gelegentlich auch mal Dinge zu verändern.
Könnte man natürlich sagen, so wie die das jetzt durchdrücken, hast du versagt? Ist fies, ich weiß, das hört sich fies an, aber alle wedeln hier mit den Armen und sagen dann, oh Gott, furchtbar, furchtbar.
Das wäre zu ambitioniert zu sagen, da hab ich versagt. Das ist nicht die Ebene, auf der wir unmittelbar intervenieren können. Was der Rat hinter geschlossenen Türen beschließt, das entzieht sich der Einflussnahme nicht nur der Zivilgesellschaft, für die wir herstehen, sondern auch derjenigen der anderen EU-Institutionen namentlich des Parlaments. Das Parlament wird da wirklich einfach über den Tisch gezogen.
Andreas, wir hatten ganz am Anfang der Sendung schon darüber gesprochen, dass jetzt am 25. März, also am Montag, wichtige Entscheidungen gefällt wurden im Parlament, das ja nicht in Brüssel getagt hat diesmal, und auch im Innenministerrat und vielleicht kannst du ein bisschen erzählen, was dort diskutiert wurde, was davon nach außen gedrungen ist, dass die Hörer auch ein bisschen mehr erfahren, wie der aktuelle politische Stand jetzt ist.
Die Entscheidung im Parlament ist genau gesagt im Innenausschuss des Parlaments gefallen, der beim Europäischen Parlament Ausschuss für Justiz, Inneres und Bürgerrechte heißt. In diesem Ausschuss wurde abgestimmt über eine Vorlage des Rats, die seit dem Frühsommer hier in Brüssel bekannt ist und diskutiert wird über die Einführung biologischer, biometrischer Merkmale in Pässen und Reisedokumenten. Reisedokumente sind in dem Fall vor allem Misa. Darüber hat sich das Parlament ziemlich lange den Kopf zerbrochen. Der Berichterstatter ist ein portugiesischer Konservativer, der von seiner politischen Ausrichtung her natürlich so wohl gerne was der Flüchtlingsabwehr machen würde, als er auch Überwachung nicht vollkommen unaufgeschlossen gegenübersteht. Andererseits ist es doch auch jemand, der so das Gefühl hat, gewisse Mindeststandards müssen gewahrt bleiben. Das Ganze muss irgendwie eine Form haben, dass es eben für den Bürger auch akzeptabel ist. Und darüber hat er sich sehr lange den Kopf zerbrochen, hat ein Hearing mit Experten veranstaltet, in dem diese Experten ihm erzählt haben, wie problematisch Biometrie ist. Und einer dieser Experten hat zum Beispiel gemeint, dass man noch mindestens 25 Jahre warten müsste, bis diese Technologie sowohl technologisch, aber vor allem auch, was die soziale Ursachenabschätzung angeht, soweit wäre, dass man sie einführen könnte. Das hat leider alles nichts geholfen. Das Parlament hat schon so abgestimmt, dass die biometrischen Merkmale eingeführt werden sollen. Allerdings mit so jede Menge schönen klingenden Sätzchen außen rum, die das akzeptabler machen sollen. Das war aber sowieso alles für die Katz. Denn so ziemlich gleichzeitig hat 100 Kilometer weiter in Luxemburg der Rat der Innenminister getagt, wo Deutschland von Frau Zyprez und Herrn Schillie vertreten war. Und dieser Rat der Innenminister hat beschlossen, die Grundlage, über die das Parlament abgestimmt hat, mal eben zu ändern, während das Parlament noch dabei ist, drüber abzustimmen und jetzt also nicht nur eins, sondern mindestens zwei biometrische Merkmale einzuführen. Soll also da jetzt noch zu dem digitalen Foto, zu dem sogenannten Face-Scan, soll auch noch der Fingerabdruck dazu kommen. Und für diejenigen, denen das immer noch nicht reicht, ist das auch ein Scan der Iris. Diejenigen, denen das nicht reicht, das zeichnet sich auch schon ab, zu denen wird Deutschland wohl gehören. Denn Deutschland war einer der beiden Staaten, die dieses betrieben haben, neben England.
Passiert so was öfter, dass die Grundlagen geändert werden, gerade wenn die Entscheidungen woanders getroffen werden?
Naja, also dieses zärtliche Übereintreffen, dass es innerhalb weniger Stunden beide Entscheidungen fallen, das ist schon entweder sehr große Dreistigkeit oder einigermaßen großer Zufall. Es passiert natürlich immer wieder, dass das Parlament über irgendwelche Dinge abstimmt und dann die Mitteilung kriegt. Das sei jetzt obsolet, das hätte man sich auch schenken können. Es kommt einfach daher, dass die EU, was Innen- und Justizpolitik angeht, im engeren Sinn keine Demokratie ist. Das Parlament kann da nämlich nur seine Meinung abgeben und der Rat kann oder kann auch nicht diese Meinung in Betracht ziehen. Und meistens tut das nicht.
Diese Konfusion bringt uns jetzt eine Möglichkeit, dass wir noch mal einhaken können als Zivilgesellschaft. Ich meine, wenn jetzt diese Grundlage weggezogen wurde von der Parlamentsentscheidung, bleibt davor noch irgendwas übrig von der Parlamentsentscheidung oder müssen die jetzt praktisch nochmal mit einem neuen Ratsvorschlag kommen?
Ne, die Parlamentsentscheidung ist auch nicht sehr viel weniger als was sie sonst gewesen wäre, denn in diesem sogenannten Konsultationsverfahren, das also so den ganzen Bereich Justiz und Inneres und damit auch den gesamten Bereich der Überwachung betrifft, hat das Parlament im Allgemeinen nur seine Meinung abzugeben. Es fasst diese Meinung zwar in Änderungsanträge und es kriegt dann in der Regel so sechs Wochen später vom Rat einen kleinen Brief hinzugestellt, in der Form einer Liste drin steht, diese und diese und diese Änderungsanträge haben wir eingearbeitet und diese und diese und diese und diese und diese Änderungsanträge haben wir mit Änderungen eingearbeitet und diese und diese Änderungsanträge und auch ganz viele mehr sind uns nur egal, mit denen haben wir überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Aber das ist doch komisch ein bisschen, weil doch die Parlamentarier in Brüssel, wie auch hier in Deutschland, haben keine Möglichkeit haben, dort einzugreifen, was dort diskutiert wird.
Naja, sicher. Also in diesem ganzen Bereich, den man ja, den ich ja als Kernbereich des politischen verstehen würde, da ist es tatsächlich so, dass das Eingreifen der Parlamentarier, die Möglichkeit zum Eingreifen der Parlamentarier, nicht sehr viel größer sind, als die Möglichkeiten zum Eingreifen von uns anderen Leuten, die wir uns auch hinstellen können und sagen, da gibt es eine Schweinerei, was da weiter betrieben ist.
Ja, da müssen wir aber irgendwie jetzt in die Öffentlichkeit, also wenn wir das anprangern wollen, müssen wir irgendwie andere Wege suchen, weil wenn das über das Parlament nicht geht.
Schili hört bestimmt gerade zu und lacht und wahrscheinlich mit solchen Worten wie komm mal, komm mal Brigitte, sind die süß? Wird denn auch über sowas diskutiert, also wenn über Gefahren gesprochen wird, weil wir natürlich da auch viel über Missbrauch nachdenken von der anderen Verwendbarkeit solcher Merkmale, wird da auch darüber gesprochen, dass dann da restriktive Maßnahmen ergriffen werden. Das meint WinClub, die und die Merkmale dürfen da und da nicht verwendet werden, die dürfen nur in dieser Datenbank sein oder wird darüber gar nicht geredet?
Na ja, zunächst mal der Gebrauch ist ja schon ein Missbrauch. Es ist ja so, dass die europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, die in der sogenannten Artikel 29 Arbeitsgruppe zusammengeschlossen sind, sich schon dahingehend geäußert haben, dass ihrer Meinung nach dieser ganze Biometriezirkus in den Ausweisen gegen verschiedene Prinzipien des Datenschutzes verstößt. Das ist eine Meinung, der man sich nur anschließen kann. Darüber hinaus besteht natürlich, ist es so, dass diese biometrischen Merkmale eine Scheinsicherheit schaffen. Denn es wird zwar sehr viel drüber geredet, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Person zuzuordnen aufgrund dieses und jenes Merkmals. Da gehen die Zahlen unglaublich aufeinander. Die einen reden da also im Promille oder noch kleineren Bereich, während andere sagen, in der Praxis hat man Fehlerquoten von bis zu 40 Prozent bei den Gesichtscans. Jetzt könnte man sagen, eine Überwachungstechnologie oder eine potentielle Überwachungstechnologie, bei der kann es uns ja nur recht sein, wenn sie nicht funktioniert. Der Meinung bin ich in dem Fall aber nicht ganz. Denn jeder, bei dem sowas nicht funktioniert, wird damit beim Grenzübertritt und wann immer das zum Einsatz kommt, ganz massive Probleme haben. Und es schaut nicht so aus, als ob daran gedacht sei, die ganze Technik aufgrund der Probleme wieder zurück zu ziehen. Das heißt, diese Probleme kommen auf uns zu. Darüber hinaus gibt es dann auch noch, also das hier ist, wie ich mal sagen will, der legale Missbrauch. Dann gibt es auch noch den illegalen Missbrauch. Die Daten sitzen auf sogenannten RFID-Chips in den Dokumenten. Diese Chips können über geringe Entfernungen ausgelesen werden. Wie sich die Möglichkeiten, die Entfernungen zu erhöhen, über die diese Chips ausgelesen werden können. Im Moment befindet man sich in einem Bereich von unter 10 cm. Aber wie sich aufgrund des technischen Fortschritts diese Möglichkeiten in Zukunft erhöhen, das ist reine Profitie. Man kann sagen, sie werden sich erhöhen.
Also ganz klar passiv, also praktisch das Mitlauschen geht. Unter normalen Bedingungen bis zu 10 m im Labor haben sie es sogar schon bis zu 30 m geschafft.
Es kommt natürlich immer auf die Art des RFID-Chips drauf an.
Es geht aber um die, die dort wahrscheinlich eingesetzt werden.
Über die ISO 14443, über die wir später auch noch sprechen werden, wenn ich zu meinen Abkürzungen komme.
Wobei in dem Moment, wo so ein Chip über eine Entfernung von mehr als ganz wenigen Zentimetern ausgelesen kann, die Probleme gar nicht mehr so sehr wachsen. Denn wer es darauf angelegt hat, sowas auszulesen und damit irgendeinen Geh- oder Missbrauch zu betreiben, dem wird es auch gelingen, eine Situation zu schaffen, in der das Auslesen leicht fällt. Man muss dann eben nur eine Tür nehmen, wo jeder durchgeht, so dass sein Geldbeutel in der Regel auf einer bestimmten Höhe an dem Türstock vorbeigeht und da ist eben dann das Lesegerät drin.
Na gut, aber dafür haben sie ja zumindestens irgendwie angedacht, die Kommunikation zu verschlüsseln bzw. die Kommunikation nur dann aktiv werden zu lassen.
Ich denke, wir sollten uns in den Details jetzt noch nicht vertiefen. Das sind optionale zusätzliche Sicherheitsfeatures, die in den ICAO Recommendations drinstehen. Und da, wenn wir uns später noch darüber unterhalten, was es da für Möglichkeiten gibt oder nicht. Ich denke, wir können dem Ansehersitz danken für den wertvollen Beitrag, den er uns geleistet hat in Bezug auf die politische Entwicklung, die aktuell stattfindet.
Genau, und bitte weitermachen, weil es irgendwie wichtig ist, dass man das auf europäischer Ebene weiter begleitet, beobachtet und sich auch einmischt.
Ich möchte vielleicht noch mal daran erinnern, dass wir die Sachen natürlich weiter aufs engste Mitverfolgen auch versuchen werden, mehr rauszukriegen, als offiziell verlautbart wird und dass auf unserer Webseite www.edri.org immer die neuesten Nachrichten zu dem Thema zu finden sind.
Also wir machen im Anschluss an die Sendung gibt es dann irgendwie auch die Chaosradio Seite, wo irgendwie die Links auch alle wieder verlinkt werden.
Für den Fall, dass ihr die Abkürzung nicht alle mitschreiben könnt. Andreas, halt die Ohren steif, wir sprechen uns dann beim genetischen Fingerabdruck, ne? Ach, ich liebe Schwarz-Serie. Aber leider ist es auch immer ein sehr trauriger Job. Wir können ja mal so langsam, ich denke mal, das ist Einleitung genug für diejenigen, die auch noch gar nicht gewusst haben, worum es sich bei Biometrie dreht. Ihr könnt anrufen, wenn ihr möchtet. Und mit uns reden heute Abend im Blue Moon, weil das soll ja nicht nur Monolog hier von unserer Seite sein. Ihr könnt vielleicht, also ich weiß ja nicht, was für ein Gefühl ihr jetzt bekommt in Berlin und Brandenburg. Ob euch das gefällt oder nicht, aber habt ihr Angst vor dieser Biometrie, die jetzt kommt und werdet ihr euch jetzt bevor diese neuen Ausweise und Pässe kommen schnell noch welche machen lassen, weil so ein Pass hält ja auch 10 Jahre. Und mit so einer Übergangsregelung, die auch in den USA gelten wird.
Wenn du das Glück hast 26 oder älter zu sein, dann gelten Ausweise 10 Jahre.
Stimmt, ah okay, ich bin ja von mir aus gegangen, obwohl ich noch 18 bin.
Noch im Moment, das wird sich nämlich auch ändern, dazu später mehr.
Wieso wird einem eigentlich immer sofort die Planke unter den Füßen weggerissen, wenn man gerade versucht, die ersten G-Versuche zu machen?
Ja, das ist Chaosradio.
Ja, das ist Chaosradio. 0331 77 97 110 ist auf jeden Fall die Telefonnummer von Fritz und die hat sich noch nicht geändert. Ruft an, was haltet ihr von Biometrie? Ist das was, was ihr euch wünscht, auch um zur Sicherheit beizutragen, zu allgemeinen in der Welt, weil, wie wir ja an dem TUI-Prozess, wo heute die Entscheidung gefallen ist, gemerkt haben, Terrorismus ist überall und ist normal und gehört einfach zum Leben dazu. Gehören dann auch biometrische Merkmale zum Leben dazu, die in eurem Pest gespeichert werden. 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben es 23 Uhr, das heißt eine Stunde ist schon rum. Zwei Stunden geht es noch vom Blue Moon. Heute Abend, am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Natürlich mit Chaos Computer Club Menschen im Studio. Das ist unter anderem der Harald und Starbuck und dann noch Peter ist selber auch Dozent von der HU. Sachen Informatik, wir nennen ihn heute Abend dann mal unseren Gastdozent. Thema ist Biometrie und eure Meinung ist gefragt, was haltet ihr davon? Also möchtet ihr das wirklich, dass demnächst in euren Pässen, in euren Ausweisen kleine Sachen untergebracht sind, die euren Fingerabdruck kenntlich machen und alle möglichen Sachen auslesbar sind, weil es auf einem RFID-Chip gespeichert ist? Also ich übertreibe jetzt natürlich mal ein bisschen, aber es ist ja schon heftig.
Das ist keine Übertreibung.
Ich übertreibe jetzt überhaupt nicht. Am Telefon ist der Carsten aus Berlin, namens Carsten.
Jo, ihr hattet die Hörerschaft oft gerufen, mal ein Statement abzugeben und deswegen rufe ich an.
Tu das.
Genau. Und was ich sagen wollte, ist eigentlich nur, ich wollte den Hörern eine Empfehlung geben zu dem Thema. Es ist ein Buchtipp und der Autor heißt Armin Rischi, kennt vielleicht der eine oder andere und der Titel heißt Machtwechsel auf Erden. Und da geht es genau um diese Thematik und das Buch ist ungefähr so 697 erschienen und dort beschreibt er das, was so in den letzten zwölf Monaten zu dieser Thematik in der Öffentlichkeit auch dokumentiert wurde, sehr explizit und genau und erklärt auch, worum das alles so passiert und welche Interessen da eigentlich dahinterstehen. Denn das wurde ja alles zurzeit unter dem Deckmantel der Staatssicherheit durchgezogen und das ist natürlich irgendwie nur so eine Art Deckmantel.
Ganz einfach, wie willst du vielleicht den Buchtipp irgendwie an unsere Mailadresse schicken? Und wie erstmal für alle 97 at chaosradio.ccc.de und dann tun wir das im Anschluss auf unsere Seite und dann kann es irgendwie jeder nochmal genau durchlesen. Also einfach schicken und dann tun wir es dann mit drauf.
97 at chaosradio.ccc.de, die emailadresse ist.
Sagt mal Jungs, können wir ein bisschen lauter reden für euch? Ganz schlecht.
Das können wir leider schlecht beeinflussen. Also das liegt vielleicht auch an deinem Telefon. Das ist manchmal der Fall, aber relativ selten. Vielleicht könntest du ja mal kurz, weil du gesagt hast, bevor sich jetzt alle das Buch holen, du hast gesagt, was da unter dem Deckmantel alles eigentlich passieren soll, könntest du mal die drei prominentesten Beispiele dessen nennen, was da unter dem Deckmantel passiert? Weil du hast das Ding ja gelesen, nehme ich an. Ist ja nicht nur eine Empfehlung aus dem Kalten.
Es ist richtig, ja. Ich rede jetzt von diesen Ereignissen, zum Beispiel Tollcollect. Dieses Überwachungssystem, dieses gigantische, was da installiert werden soll oder schon ist teilweise. Und was ja auch europaweit, weltweit dann mal vertrieben werden soll. Das ist ein Element von dieser Sache. Also die logische Konsequenz sind dann diese Chips. Das ist alles, dazu da ein totalitäres Überwachungssystem a la Staatsfeind Nummer 1 zu installieren. Ja und du hast mich jetzt gefragt, was die Hintergründe sind, ja?
Weil du gesagt hast, dass unter diesem Deckmantel, dessen das ganze Terrorismusbekämpfung ist, hast du gesagt, da sind ein paar prominente Beispiele, die vielleicht nicht unbedingt Tollcollect, weil wir sind ja jetzt nicht alle Trucker.
Ja, damit kann man ja auch jeden Pkw-Fahrer auf einer Autobahn identifizieren. Richtig.
Und darf man mittlerweile in manchen Bundesländern schon in Bayern und in Sachsen sind bereits Gesetze durch, nach denen die von Brücken aus Kameras, Kfz-Kennzeichen ablesen können, diese Daten auch im Zweifelsfall abgefragt und recherchiert werden können.
Ach, da fühl ich mich doch gleich besser. Ja gut, ansonsten lassen wir die Buchempfehlung einfach mal so stehen und dann können ja mal jeder reinlesen, wenn er möchte. Danke für den Anruf.
Ich begrüße noch alle Amigane da draußen und den Tim Friedloff.
Den Tim Friedloff, ja, das richten wir ihm dann nochmal persönlich aus, wenn er nicht schon schlafen sollte. Wahrscheinlich ruft er gleich an und sagt, er ist am Leben. Oliver aus Schwellen ist am Telefon. Hallo Oliver.
Ja, wunderbar, dass es mal geklappt hat.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ja, wer am Anfang anruft, wird sofort belohnt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall frage ich mich überhaupt bei solchen Systemen, inwieweit das überhaupt vorbeugend über mein wegen terroristische Anschläge sein kann.
Weil ich denke mir mal, dass wenn jemand in den Flussdurch reinschleicht und zwei Hochhäuser wieder umlegt, wie weit dann überhaupt sowas nutzt.
Also, ist ja schön, wenn sie da einen Fingerabdruck haben, aber man kann da gar nicht mehr so Ausschlag geben.
Die Aussage ist ganz klar, nutzt also nichts, würde ich nicht sagen, aber sehr, sehr wenig. Also die Einschnitte, die damit verbunden sind, stehen dem Nutzen und gar keinem Vergleich gegenüber.
Na, gehen wir doch mal von dem tatsächlichen praktischen Beispiel der Attentäter vom 11. September aus. Die waren hier in Deutschland ganz legal gemeldet. Die hatten ganz normale Ausweise. Die sind völlig legal, ohne dass irgendetwas Eigenartiges gewesen wäre, mit gültigen Reisedokumenten in die USA eingereist. Und so würden die in fünf Jahren auch wieder einreisen, wenn es biometrische Feste gibt.
In einem Fall wussten die sogar, dass der Typ möglicherweise eine Gefahr darstellt und haben es aber erst mal ignoriert und weggesteckt. Also sie wussten ja sehr viel mehr, als dass da einfach nur jemand eingereist ist.
Und das ohne Biometrie in Ausweisdokumenten.
Sie wussten ja alles, sie wussten ja schon viel zu viel.
Und ohne Homeland Security.
Das ist so wie, es war vorhin die Diskussion, es war ein anderes Thema, aber einer unserer Techniker meinte, das ist halt eben nur ein Stift, mit dem man eben tolle Sachen malen oder schreiben kann, wenn man malen oder schreiben kann. Aber wenn man das nicht tut, dann bleibt es ein Stift und es bleibt nur ein Werkzeug und man kann nichts damit anfangen.
Ich denke mal, das Thema ist eigentlich in der gleichen Schiene so wie CCPA, dass man da einfach versucht, von den großen Regierungen und von den großen Betrieben ein richtiges Überwachungssystem einzurichten, dass man nicht nur den Gläsern zu tun hat, sondern auch den Gläsern Menschen überhaupt im eigenen Staat hat.
Es gibt natürlich einen Kontext, in dem das Ganze passiert. Also was jetzt gerade wieder in der Diskussion war, Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Telekommunikationsverkehrsdaten. Das ist ein solch ein Bereich, wir haben Tollcollektion genannt. Im Bereich des Urheberrechts, die Sachen mit Digital Rights Management, da fallen auch sehr viele Personenbezogene Daten an. Und das ist natürlich ein ganzer Komplexen. Also das streut quer durch alle Gesellschaftsbereiche. Und es ist eigentlich auch keiner mehr nicht betroffen. Also spätestens bei den Ausweisen. Also wenn es dann in die Personalausweise geht, dann ist eigentlich jeder betroffen. Den man erstmal so ganz extrem sehen würde.
Aber kann man sich auch so sehen, dass zum Beispiel, also jetzt mal um ein schönes Bild zu zeichnen, wenn dann irgendwann diese ganzen Möglichkeiten da sind, kann man dann nicht auch erwarten, dass die Gesellschaft, wenn sie mit diesen Sachen auch groß wird und sich dran gewöhnt, dann eben einen etwas lockereren Umgang damit pflegt und eben halt nicht alles irgendwie auf die Goldware gelegt, sondern dass man einfach lockerer damit umgehen kann, weil man im Zweifelsfall sehr genau sagen kann, was war.
Nee, das Problem ist einfach, dass man dann Angst hat und sich nicht so verhält, wie man sich normalerweise verhalten würde.
Genau. Ja, das ist die Heisenbergische Unschärfe-Relation. Je genauer ich hingucke, umso mehr verändert sich das.
Ja, es gab da tatsächlich direkt einen Begriff für, dass sich halt Leute, wenn sie sich anders verhalten, weil sie beobachtet werden. Ich komme aber gerade nicht auf den Namen.
Na ist ja auch letztendlich, ich meine, es ist völlig klar, dass sich ein Mensch anders verhält, wenn er weiß, er wird beobachtet, als sonst, insbesondere wenn er weiß, er wird beobachtet und diese Beobachtungsdaten werden auch noch alle gespeichert und können im Nachhinein irgendwo abgerufen werden. Er weiß ganz genau, wenn ich mal kombiniere, was so ein Mensch für digitale Informationen überall hinterlässt, angefangen von im Internet irgendwelche Informationen, Verbindungen, dann Telefonverbindungsdaten, hat er ein Handy, dann die Orte, an denen er die Zellen, an denen er mit seinem Handy eingebucht war, dann fährt er mit dem Auto, dann das Kfz-Kennzeichen, wo er wann war, dann gibt es vielleicht das elektronische Ticket in der BVG irgendwann mal, das ist ja auch noch nicht vom Tisch, dann weiß man auch genau, wann er wohnt, in welche Straßenbahn ein oder ausgestiegen ist.
Und letztendlich zum Schluss dann halt noch Überwachungskameras überall und dann wirst du halt überall überwacht. Also praktisch jeder Schritt von dir kann dann verfolgt werden.
Wahrscheinlich machen sie dann noch so richtig schöne Sachen, wo dann per Satellit einfach nur so eine kleine RFID-Momentaufnahme von einer Perzelle gemacht werden kann. Du kannst dann ganz genau sehen, wie die Bevölkerungsverteilung innerhalb dieses Bereiches auf dem Platz gewesen ist.
Das kann man jetzt schon eigentlich.
Naja, nicht per Satellit. Ja, aber einfach irgendwie tief fliegende, autonome Drohnen. Also die Israelis setzen die zum Beispiel in den Palästinenser-Gebieten ein, das ist irgendwie gar nicht lustig. Die sind halt wirklich autonom und klein und billig und werden halt halt irgendwie fliegende halt schon die ganze Zeit rum und übermachen.
Auf den Dingern steht unten drauf, wir sind auch autonom. Ja, Oliver, Mensch, da hacken wir in die gleiche Kerbe.
Ja, denke ich mal auch.
Ich denke mal, wenn man dich dann überall beobachtet fühlen soll, dann ist ja nicht mehr wirklich so das gegeben, was man eigentlich in einem Staat oder in einem Land sucht. Also dann ist man pauschal eigentlich, für die Beobachtenden ist man dann pauschal erst mal Verbrecher, Terrorist, lalala.
Die Staatssicherheit hätte sich gefreut, ob diese Möglichkeiten.
Was ich meinte, ich probier's ja nochmal positiv, ob Leute sich dann nicht in dieser Tatsache auch bewusster sind und ihre Bürgerrechte aktiver durchsetzen möchten und sich auch bewusster sind, was sie tun dürfen und was nicht, wenn sie denn beobachtet werden?
Das Problem ist einfach, wenn dieses ganze Überwachungsszenario sich erst mal etabliert hat, dann wird man nicht mehr die Möglichkeit haben, eine opportunistische Meinung zu haben. Also dann, sobald man schief denkt, wird man dann wahrscheinlich sofort, ja, was auch immer, kann man sich selber ausmalen.
Das Problem ist natürlich, wenn man sich jetzt die Videokameras anschaut, man stumpft ja irgendwann mal ab, man hält es für normal, dass überall Videokameras hängen und man macht sich nicht mehr die Mühe, dass man dann zu dem Betreiber geht und ihn fragt, hast du da überhaupt eine Grundlage für, wie sieht das mit den Gesetzen aus, musst du da nicht Schild dahin machen und und und.
Wo war das neulich? Seattle oder so, wo sie diese neuen Kameras installiert haben, diese tollen 2600 Kameras im Stadtgebiet, 360 Grad schwenkbar, 400-facher Zoom plus Nachtsicht, da könnt ihr jeden Pickel erkennen, den ich mir unrechtmäßig an irgendeiner Wand ausbreche.
Ich glaub San Francisco und im Anschluss daran hat sich irgendeine Gruppe hingesetzt und hat irgendwie eine Software, also hat erstmal die ganzen Kameras erfasst und dann eine Software geschrieben, die einem anzeigt, wo man langlaufen muss, um nicht erfasst zu werden. Und ich hab irgendwie so einen Screenshot gesehen, das waren irgendwie echt Umwege, das glaubt man gar nicht. Also dreimal außenrum, um dann um die Ecke zu kommen.
Das ist eine schöne Sache, weil das ist sehr markant. Die Software, also zumindest die New Yorker-Ableger davon, der älter ist, der stammt von einer Institution, die nennt sich Institut für angewandte Autonomie. Das ist doch sehr schön. Also ich mein, das macht es halt plastisch, wie groß das Problem ist. Also im Stadtgebiet Manhattan kann man gar nicht mehr rumlaufen, ohne dass man auf einer gerader Strecke nicht an jeder Ecke 2 bis 15 Kameras hat. Das geht nicht.
Oliver, danke für den Anruf.
Ja, kein Problem.
Gruß nach Schwelm. So, dann noch schnell der Christoph aus Berlin. Hallo Christoph.
Ja, hallo.
Guten Abend.
Ja, ich wollte einfach nur mal, ja weiß ich auch nicht, was zu erzählen zu dem Thema. Und zwar denke ich mal, dass ja wieder der Versuch ist, ein soziales, politisches Problem mit Technik zu lösen. Und ich denke, dass es halt einfach schon daran scheitert. Also ich hab jetzt, vielleicht habt ihr ihn auch gesehen, Fahrenheit 911 gesehen. Da wurde die Sicherheitsberaterin des US-Präsidenten interviewt und der hat ja eine Akte bekommen, die sich jetzt ausgestellt hat von seinem, weiß ich nicht, von seinem Terroristen-Chefberater da, wo halt drin stand, dass die Al-Qaeda eben genau dieses Attentat durchführen wird, das sie dann auch durchgeführt hat und hat ihn auch ignoriert und die Frau Reis wurde da gefragt, ob denn diese Überschrift zu dieser Akte eindeutig gewesen wäre und sie meinte dann, nein, die wäre sehr uneindeutig gewesen, das hätte sowas geheißen, wie Al-Qaeda greift Hochhäuser mit Flugzeugen an. Also in dieser Situation hilft natürlich dann auch keine Technik mehr, das ist klar und ich finde, das sollten sich, ja das ist einfach, das wird deswegen einfach nicht funktionieren, weil es eben kein technisches Problem ist und man es technisch nicht lösen kann. Man kann Terroristen nicht irgendwie technisch identifizieren.
Das ist Quatsch.
Man kann aber die Volksgruppe, aus der sich die Terroristen rekrutieren, gemeinschaftlich unter Terrorverdacht stellen.
Klar und die kann man dann auch alle nach Guantanamo schicken.
Vor allem ist ja auch immer diese obscure Vorstellung, Terroristen werden grundsätzlich immer aus dem Ausland und werden grundsätzlich immer irgendwelche islamistischen Fundamentalisten oder was auch immer. Das ist ja schon der Zugschluss Nummer eins. Es gab ja auch in den USA sowas wie Oklahoma und in Deutschland mal sowas wie die RAF und dergleichen. Das sind auch keine bösen Ausländer, die ich an der Grenze aufgrund eines biometrischen Ausweises identifizieren kann, weil sie mal sonst irgendwann in irgendeinem Trainingslager waren.
Um es mal auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Da sehe ich auch noch ein ganz großes Problem an dieser Geschichte. Also gar nicht so sehr in diesem Versuch, diese Technik durchzudrücken auch. Sondern auch ein großes Problem sehe ich einfach daran, wie es auch bei den Software-Patenten gelaufen ist und wie es der Schili jetzt auch versucht, so wie es Cyprus ja auch getan hat, man umgeht den Bundestag, indem man einfach versucht, das im Europäischen Rat, also im Europäischen Rat das einfach beschließt. Und das Europäische Parlament hat ja nun einfach, wie habe ich jetzt gerade mal nachgelesen, keine Initiativgewalt. Das heißt, die können im Prinzip keinen Gegenvorschlag machen. Die können das nur abnicken oder sich nochmal 20-mal vorlegen lassen. Und versucht so natürlich, so das Parlament zu umgehen. Und auch das Europäische Parlament ist ja gegen solche Vorschläge. Das war bei den Software-Patenten schon so. Das ist jetzt auch schon wieder so und wird trotzdem ignoriert. Weil sie wissen, dass sie bei keinem Parlament damit durchkommen, weder im Bundestag noch im Europäischen. Machen sie es halt so. Und da sehe ich eigentlich, das ist für mich fast noch ein, naja, das ist mindestens genauso schwerwiegend, denke ich. Also ich denke, da müsste man ansetzen. Ja, also auch dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Verfassungsrichtlinie für das Europäische Parlament dann wirklich auch kommt, die dem Europäischen Parlament dann halt das Recht gibt, so einen Initiativantrag zu stellen.
Ja, stimme ich dir zu, ist mit Sicherheit, diese undemokratischen Verhältnisse auf europäischer Ebene sind mit Sicherheit einer der wesentlichen Gründe, warum wir so ganz eigenartige Entscheidungsszenarien haben, gerade wie Software-Patentproblematik eben zeigt. Und da müsste sicherlich mal grundlegend was getan werden, um hier das zu... Nichtsdestotrotz ist das auch kein Allheilmittel. Also ich meine, irgendwelche Parlamente sind auch schnell überzeugt, der Schili, der Autokatalog ist auch abgenickt worden von einem Parlament in Deutschland und ja...
Aber es zeigt natürlich auch, welche Einstellungen zur Demokratie diese Leute haben, also der Schili insbesondere auch.
Den hat die Demokratie eingestellt, so viel zur Einstellung zur Demokratie. Naja, es ist halt schwierig. Ich glaube, gerade der Autokatalog, das war halt eine Sache, die man von der Seite nicht erwartet hätte. Da war dann schon keiner mehr überrascht, weil es einfach merkwürdig war, dass es von der Seite kommt. Da haben die noch dunkleren Leute gesagt, oh, lustig.
Richtig, da war der Backstein ja dann auf einmal nicht mehr rechts genug.
Ja, wir fühlen mit dir, Christoph. Danke für den Anruf. So, ja gut, okay, aber was sollen wir machen? Wir müssen drüber reden. Über Standards sollten wir reden. Was für Standards sollen da überhaupt kommen bei dieser ganzen Biometrie? Wir müssen sich ja irgendwas überlegen. Sollen wieder schöne bunte Pässe sein, wahrscheinlich aus Plastik, irgendwas soll piepen und was weiß ich nicht was. Wie wird sowas überhaupt aussehen?
Ja, das ist also eben eine Sache, die in dieser ICAO, die ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe, oder ICAO diskutiert wird, die International Civil Aviation Organization. Das ist eine Organisation, die 1944 glaube ich zum ersten Mal diskutiert wurde, 1946 dann als PCAO, als Preliminary International Civil Aviation Organization gegründet wurde. Und es ging einfach darum, erstmal Navigationsstandards für den internationalen zivilen Luftverkehr zu schaffen und überhaupt so einheitliches Prozedere, was also Navigationssysteme und Kommunikation zwischen Piloten und Flughäfen, Luftüberwachung dergleichen betrifft. Also zur einen Seite natürlich technisch, auf der anderen Seite sehr international. 1947 wurde das dann offiziell irgendwie von 52 Ländern oder so, also 52 Länder waren daran beteiligt und es wurde zu einem UN-Untergremium ernannt oder eben gemacht. Und hat sich seitdem mit allen möglichen Dingen, die mit Luftfahrt im entferntesten zusammenhängen, beschäftigt, unter anderem auch mit den sogenannten MRTDs, mit den Machine Readable Travel Documents, also Maschinenlesbaren Reisedokumente. Die haben wir jetzt schon alle, die Maschinenlesbaren Reisedokumente, also in Deutschland zumindest, wenn man sich so einen Reisefass ansieht oder auch selbst beim Personalausweis, da gibt es unten so zwei oder eine Zeile, also auf jeden Fall eine Zeile, es wird immer als Zone bezeichnet in den Standards, die ist in so einer komischen Schrift geschrieben, die sieht so aus wie auf den Kfz-Zehnzeichen oder zumindest ähnlich wie auf den Kfz-Kennzeichen, das ist die sogenannte OCR-Schriftart. Das ist eine Schriftart, die dafür gedacht ist, von Maschinen gelesen zu werden. Und die Art und Weise, wo auf einem Reisedokument diese Informationen wie Ausweisnummer, Geburtsdatum, derartige Dinge niedergeschrieben sind, das ist also auch schon durch diese ICHO-Organisation spezifiziert worden. Die hat also schon eine Geschichte dessen, Standards zu setzen, was internationale Reisedokumente betrifft. Und diese Organisation hat sich dann im Zuge des Schreis nach Biometrie in Folge auf den 11. September eben damit beschäftigt, wie man auf einem international einheitlichen Standard biometrische Daten in Ausweisen oder an Ausweisen anbringen kann. Das also jetzt zu dieser Organisation als Hintergrund. Und diese ganzen Dokumente, die diese ICHO erarbeitet hat, die kann man sich auch herunterladen. Die machen also da keine Geheimniskrämerei oder zumindest tun sie nicht so, als ob sie Geheimnisse hätten, sondern sie veröffentlichen Dokumente, ob die Intern noch mal was anderes machen, das weiß man natürlich auch nicht. Aber diese Dokumente, die kann man sich herunterladen auf der Webseite. Das ist also einiges. Es ist erstmal ein sogenannter Technical Report für Biometrics Deployment of Machine Readable Travel Documents. Dieser Report ist so die Grundlage. Und dann gibt es da 1000 Anhänge dazu, in denen die Details stehen. Kann man sich also damit beschäftigen, wenn man das interessiert tun möchte. So, was droht uns denn nun konkret? Was schreiben die denn da drin über solche Ausweise? Es steht drin, dass man sich grundsätzlich, was man haben möchte, ist irgendwo ein digitales biometrisches Merkmal. Da kann man anfangen von Gesicht, also Bild eines Gesichtes, Fingerabdrücke und dergleichen, das hatten wir ja schon alles angesprochen. Das muss ich jetzt auf einem Ausweiss speichern. Ein Ausweis ist ja normalerweise ein Stück Papier, ein bisschen in Plastik eingeschweißt, mit einem Pappetdeckel außenrum und so. Da ist ja keine CD, kann ich nicht irgendwo in den Laufwerk legen. Jetzt kann ich anfangen, da kann ich Barcodes zu machen, zweidimensionale Barcodes, irgendwelche optischen Speicher, Magnetstreifen, was auch immer für Speichertechnologien. Und man hat sich dafür entschieden, sogenannte RFID, oder ich persönlich bezeichne die als ISO 14443-Chips, falls es einfacher ist. Genau, das eben aussagt, worum es geht. RFID ist wieder so ein Dunstbegriff, der mit allen möglichen Dingen... Es gibt eben sogenannte contactless integrated circuits. Das heißt, es sind Chips, die über Funk wellen, ohne dass da ein Kontakt da ist. Bei der Telefonkarte hab ich Kontakte, die sehe ich auf der Karte. So ist das nicht, sondern es ist ein Chip, der da irgendwo drin ist, der über Funk kommuniziert mit dem Lesegerät. So was soll also in den Ausweis eingebracht werden. So ein kontaktloses IC. Und da drin sollen dann zum einen die Daten gespeichert werden, die sowieso im Ausweis stehen, wie Name, Geburtsort, Geburtsdatum, diese ganzen Dinge, Staatszugehörigkeit, vielleicht ein Wohnort, was halt im Ausweis auch eingedruckt ist. Das wird also da drin stehen in digitaler Form. Dazu alles auch das, was in der Maschinenlesbahnzeile steht, das heißt das, was sowieso schon jetzt mit OCL optisch gelesen werden kann, das steht da auch noch mit drin. Und dann eben auch die biometrischen Daten. Und als Mindestmerkmal für alle Staaten, die diese internationalen, standardisierten Reisedokumente einführen, wird hier ein Bild, ein Bild, das das Gesicht der Person abgespeichert werden. Das ist also das Mindestanforderung. Es muss also die Daten, die sowieso auf dem Papier stehen, plus das Bild muss dort elektronisch vorliegen. Und alles darüber hinaus ist optional. Ich kann optional Ihres haben, ich kann optional ein oder mehrere Finger haben und so weiter. Das ist alles optional, aber für die Mindestinteroperabilität zwischen den Ländern und dafür, dass man mit diesem Standard in Übereinstimmung steht, wird also dieses Bild abgespeichert. Das ist also das, wo der internationale Standard ist. Der Chip selber, das wird ein sogenannter DIN EN ISO IEC 7816 kompatibler Chip sein. Nochmal. Ein DIN EN ISO IEC 7816. Da gibt es dann noch Unterkapitel, das ist dann DIN EN ISO IEC 7816-4 und 8-7. Die kennt man eigentlich schon, wenn man mit Chipkarten ein bisschen zu tun hat, dann weiß man, was das ist.
Aber ein bisschen zu tun gehabt.
Genau, man oberflächlich so ein bisschen diese Standards hineingelesen hat. Das ist ein Standard. Dieses ISO 1443 beschreibt sozusagen, wie diese Funksignale aufgebaut sind, wie kommuniziert wird zwischen dem Lesegerät und dem Chip. Und dieses 7816 mit den unterschiedlichen Kapiteln, das bezeichnet dann, wenn Verschlüsselung ausgehandelt wird, wie authentiziert sich die Karte gegenüber dem Leser oder umgekehrt, was für Befehle werden dort gesprochen usw. Das sind dann eben die höheren Schichten. Ja, das also mal jetzt zu meinem Monolog. Erstmal über das, was da passiert. Ich habe natürlich noch mehr Informationen, gerade wenn es dann darum geht, um die Sicherheit, wer kann das auslesen usw. Aber ich denke, wir machen erst mal eine kurze Pause.
Jetzt wird es doch gerade so spannend, die Sicherheitsfragen.
Ich kann auch gleich weitermachen, aber ich denke, wir geben den Hörern mal zwei Sekunden Zeit, auswendig zu lernen, in ISO EEC 7816-4.
Oder auch mal Strich 7. Das Chaosradio auftritt, wir haben es gleich halb. Gleich gibt es auch Nachrichten. Aber Thema Biometrie, der Peter hat angerufen und aus Bayreuth übrigens und wollte noch seinen Selbst dazu geben. Hallo Peter.
Eine Frage, die ich mir schon seit langer Zeit stelle, wie es sein kann, dass einmal so wenig über das Thema informiert wird und auch öffentlich diskutiert wird und zum anderen auch, dass es in Anbetracht der undemokratischen Zustände, die da auch in der EU herrschen, auch keinen nennenswerten Protest gibt.
Ja, naja, wer ist denn daran interessiert, dass eine Diskussion stattfindet? Ja, also bei diesen Themen ist es ja eben genau so, dass die entsprechenden Minister oder die Leute, die in den entsprechenden Exekutivgremien sitzen und die Entscheidungen treffen, die haben ja gar kein Interesse daran, dass öffentlich diskutiert wird. Da nehmen die auch gar kein Plattformmund. Also wenn man wieder auf diese Software-Patentgeschichte komme, da gab es mal auch ein Dokument, in dem drin stand, eben genau um kontroverse Diskussionen in der Öffentlichkeit zu umgehen, soll also hier schnell eine Entscheidung im Parlament getroffen werden.
Ja, aber die Sache ist ja doch auch ein bisschen tiefer eingreifender ins Leben der meisten Menschen, als jetzt die Geschichte um die Software-Patente, die ich eigentlich auch schon als Schweinerei sehe. Aber das geht ja nur doch ein ganzes Eck weiter.
Das kümmert die Politik heutzutage aber kaum noch, dass irgendwie ihre Bevölkerung, also ihre Wähler praktisch irgendwie in ihr Leben eingegriffen wird.
Also das ist das Problem. Ja, also außer den Leuten, die wirklich so in der Technik drinstecken, wie jetzt hier CCC oder EDRI, FIF und die ganzen Organisationen, die sich irgendwo um digitale Bürgerrechte kümmern. Außerhalb dieses Dunstkreises ist es ja relativ wenig bekannt. Vielleicht noch ein paar Computerfreaks, die irgendwie CT lesen und da stand vielleicht mal was drin. Aber ansonsten ist das einfach kein Diskussionspunkt. Und eben auch in der Politik eigentlich kein Diskussionspunkt, weil es weiß ja niemand, was über die Technik und das, was die Politiker sagen, ist auch nur das, was ihnen der Vertreter der Wirtschaft irgendwie vorher im Lobbykreis irgendwie eingeflüstert hat oder was in irgendeinem Dossier drin steht. Aber von der Technik hat ja, bis auf die wenigen Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, niemand eine Ahnung. Und deswegen haben die wenigsten auch eine Vorstellung davon, was da tatsächlich kommen wird.
Das heißt im Endeffekt ja, dass im Endeffekt keine Chance besteht, dass die Sache noch abwendbar ist, weil es ja keine Diskussion gibt und von daher auch kein Widerstand.
Das befürchten wir auch. Also vermutlich ist es einfach jetzt schon gegessen, die Sache. Also man kann vielleicht die Sachen noch mindern, also die Gefahren noch ein bisschen herabsetzen. Wir kommen nachher noch mal zu dezentraler beziehungsweise zentraler Datenspeicherung bei dem Thema, aber ansonsten ist die Sache einfach durch.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, dass es kann schon sein, dass es noch ein paar Spätsünder gibt, die dann Vorfeste irgendwo auslösen, wenn dann vielleicht das doch mal auch von Massenmedien aufgegriffen wird.
Ja, so wie bei der Privatkopie.
Ja, hat jetzt bei der Privatkopie nicht unbedingt viel gebracht. Bei Softwarepatenten zum Beispiel, das Thema zieht sich jetzt doch schon seit mindestens vier, fünf Jahren durch die Politik und es ist immer noch keine endgültige Entscheidung da. Und das ist ja doch schon mal ein Fortschritt. Also wenn wir das bei Biometrien-Ausweisdokumenten auch so hinkriegen, dann ist das doch schon mal...
Gut, man hat sich auch sehr mal ins Knie geschossen mit München Linux und Softwarepatenten.
Ja, gut, wir müssen jetzt nicht über dieses Thema diskutieren. Genau, aber ich meine nur, es gibt auch Beispiele, wo es zumindest zu einem teilweiseen Erfolg geführt hat, der Protest, obwohl es sehr technisch ist.
Also vermutlich wird es genauso wie bei der Maut laufen, dass man jetzt alles einführt und dann kommt das große Desaster und dann ist das Geschrei groß, dass wieder um vier Milliarden in den Sand gesetzt werden. Aber das Produkt ist dann da und irgendwann wird es dann auch funktionieren.
Richtig, also es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass die Zeitpläne, die sich die Herrn Minister da vorstellen, dass die alle in keinster Weise umsetzbar sind. Das betrifft sowohl die Biometrien-Ausweisdokumenten, selbst die USA müssen ja ständig verschieben ihre Richtlinien und wieder ein Jahr hinaus schieben und wieder ein Jahr hinaus schieben. Und auch was jetzt zum Beispiel die Gesundheitskarte betrifft, über die wir sicher auch noch eine kommende Chaosradio-Sendung machen werden, das sind auch die Zeitpläne, die die Politiker haben, ganz illusorisch.
Die Politiker gehören halt in Legislaturperioden, anders als unsere. Und das ist halt echt ein Problem, die wollen halt immer ganz viel fertig kriegen. Wenn ich so in meinem Zimmer aufräumen verfahren würde, bin ich immer ziemlich schnell fertig.
Vielleicht noch eine kleine Randinfo, ist jetzt ein bisschen ein Eick-off-Topic, aber es soll ja in Köln inzwischen mit Wahlcomputern stark versucht werden. In einigen Bezirken kann man wohl auch nicht mehr anders wählen. Und es ist noch, was ich so aus meinen Kreisen weiß, also ganz stark der Verdacht, dass hier manipuliert wird, bis es geht nicht mehr.
Auch ein anderes Thema?
Auch ein anderes Thema, ich sag's ganz oft, aber vielleicht könnt ihr das auch mal irgendwann aufgreifen.
Können wir machen. Danke für den Tipp. Die Australier haben es mal ganz geschickt gemacht mit einer Open Source elektronischen Wahllösung. Erwahllösung.
Peter, danke für den Anruf. 0373 77 91 0 ist auf jeden Fall die Nummer vom Chaosradio weiterhin. Und weil wir es ja schon mal erwähnt haben für den Fall, weil es ja noch nicht so viel bekannt ist, für den Fall, dass ihr irgendwie ausversehen Insider seid und ihr seid irgendwie rätselig und habt ein bisschen Wein getrunken oder so, und wollt mal was über Merkmale von den ganzen Sachen, was vielleicht auch wirklich kommt. Ja, also was wird jetzt in so einem Ding drin sein? Wie sieht das aus? Spezifikationen? Also wenn ihr Bock habt und ihr seid ausversehen Industrie-Magnat oder so, dann ruft doch einfach auch an. 0373 77 91 10. Wir reden dann auch mit euch. Wir sind da also durchaus nicht abgehindigt. Wir haben es 22.31.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter selbstverständlich. Es bleibt trocken heute Nacht. Später kann sich so ein bisschen Nebel bilden. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 8 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es anfangs neblig und trüb mit ein bisschen Regen. Später kommt zwischendurch vielleicht doch die Sonne raus. Wir haben uns jetzt das Ganze doch anders überlegt. Eigentlich sollte es ja üselig bleiben, aber es könnte werden. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 12 bis 14 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkoff.
Präsident Arafat ist offenbar ernsthaft erkrankt. Der israelische Rundfunk meldete Arafat habe das Bewusstsein verloren. Die palästinensische Führung hat sich in Arafats Hauptquartier in Ramallah im Westjordanland versammelt. Ein Berater des Präsidenten sagte jedoch, Arafat sei nur erschöpft. Im Streit um die neue EU-Kommission hat das Europaparlament den Machtkampf gewonnen. Der künftige Präsident Barroso zog noch vor der Abstimmung sein komplettes Team zurück. Viele Europaparlamentarier waren mit mehreren der aufgestellten Kommissaren nicht einverstanden. In Afghanistan sind offenbar Gefangene von US-Soldaten noch brutaler gefoltert worden als im Irak. Das berechtigt das ARD Politmagazin Kontraste. Ehemalige Gefangene schildern dort die sexuellen Misshandlungen durch US-Soldaten. Missbrauch und Gewaltexzesse seien demnach an der Tagesordnung gewesen. Zum Sport. Die Ergebnisse der Fußball-Bundesliga. Stuttgart unterliegt Bremen 1 zu 2. Nürnberg verliert gegen Schalke 0 zu 2. Mainz steigt Rostock 3 zu 1. Hamburg besiegt Freiburg 4 zu 0. Leverkusen steigt Bielefeld 3 zu 2. Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft bestreitet am 9. Juni 2006 in München das Eröffnungsspiel der Weltmeisterschaft. Das legte der Fußball-Weltverband am Abend in Frankfurt am Main fest. Der erste Gegner wird am 9. Dezember 2005 in Leipzig ausgelost. Der VG Aufritz hat keine aktuellen Meldungen. Wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Das war ihr erster berühmter Track. So meldeten sie sich dieses Jahr zurück. Und dazwischen produzierten sie so viel dreiste Musik, dass wir echt gespannt sind, welche Tracks sie live spielen werden. Die Beastie Boys live in Berlin, Donnerstag, 9. Dezember in der Max Schmilling Halle. Die Beastie Boys live und im Radio. Dreiste Musik, Tritts.
Ja, wie soll ich sagen? Es war ein Lied über ein kleines Mädchen, das über so eine Blumenwiese läuft und eine Blume nach der anderen pflückt und sich das lebensfreut. Also was harmloses, genauso für diejenigen, die es jetzt nicht verstanden haben, wie die Melodie war. Aber das Chaosradio ist natürlich nicht harmlos. Wir haben es halbzeitig hier, also halbzeitige Lähmung sozusagen. 23.36 Uhr, das heißt noch knappe anderthalb Stündchen. Thema heute Abend am letzten Mittwoch im Monat Biometrie. Harald und Peter und Starbucks und meine Person Max im Studio. Und ihr könnt natürlich weiter mitreden. 033 177 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und Constanze hat angerufen. Hallo Constanze.
Hey, meine Frage ist die Folgende, ist eigentlich ziemlich kurz und schmerzlos. Ist die DNA von einem Menschen auch ein biometrisches Merkmal?
Bei den Pässen ist das ein bisschen schwierig. Also bei Grenzkontrollen DNA-Analyse zu machen, das dauert einfach noch zu lange. Aber man arbeitet dran.
Also das heißt, in zukünftigen Szenarien kann man sich das durchaus auch noch vorstellen.
Ja, aber das kann man sich jetzt schon ansehen, wie das ungefähr sein wird, wenn man den Film Getterker sich anguckt. Dann kann man ungefähr erahnen, wie das dann aussieht.
Also wer dich gesehen hat, Keule läuft an so einem Ding vorbei, sieht aus wie so ein normales Teil, wo man auch an Bezahltoiletten am Bahnhof lang muss. Da ist ein kleines Teil, wo man nicht vorbeikommt, dann drückt man seinen Daumen irgendwo drauf, das macht Spicciccici und dann kommt aus dem Daumen irgendwie Blut ab, jetzt zappt oder aus dem Zeigefinger oder so und dann wird das schnell kontrolliert.
Du bist halt invalid, also das nicht oder du bist halt genetisch korrekt und sauber.
Constanze?
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur darauf verweisen, dass damit sozusagen auch ganz andere Daten auf preis gegeben werden können. Wir waren mir nicht ganz klar, ob es tatsächlich auch ein biometrisches Merkmal ist.
Ja, sicher ist eins, aber noch keins, was wir momentan zur Diskussion haben, wenn es um Biometrie und Ausweisdokumenten geht.
Ja, aber in Zukunft ist ja vielleicht möglich, wer weiß.
Vielleicht gibt es auch ein paar Anrufer, die was Positives zur Biometrie zu sagen haben. Also wir haben ja im Vorfeld versucht, auch jemanden einen Fürsprecher mit einzuladen, um halt das Ganze ein bisschen spannender zu machen. Der eine, der erst zugesagt hat, es hat sich dann irgendwie nicht mehr gemeldet, aber vielleicht ja ein paar Anrufer, die irgendwie auch mal eine Gegenpart übernehmen wollen.
Genau, wer möchte uns kontroverse aufmischen?
Super, wir haben ja auch alles getan, um den Boden zu bereiten die letzten anderthalb Stunden. Also im Grunde müsstet ihr euch ja eingeladen fühlen, Berlin und Brandenburg. Also der eine oder andere Biometrierer und Befürworter, bitte unter 0331 77 97 110 anrufen. Wir werden auch nicht sofort abwarten, sondern erst den Vornamen anhören, bevor wir das tun. Chris aus Berlin, hi.
Ja, also ich bin auf jeden Fall Kontrabiometrie und ich wollte eigentlich nur was zu eurer Bemerkung sagen, dass die deutschen Firmen da eigentlich auch sehr weit vorne sind. Also mich kotzt das jeden Tag an. Also wenn ich allein auf meiner S-Bahnstation lang laufe und sehe, wie viele Kameras dort montiert sind, aus dem Grund habe ich selbst mal ein bisschen recherchiert über die schicken Firmenaufkleber, die da drauf sind und habe halt auch festgestellt, dass die Firma, die das hier zum Beispiel für die S-Bahn Berlin macht, das komplette Überwachungssystem auch in London aufgesetzt hat. Auch sehr interessant zu wissen.
Vor allem, wo London sehr weit vorne ist, das würdest du damit sagen.
Kurz sagen, wie die Firma heißt, oder ist das die, die überall auf den Kameras drauf steht?
Ja, gut, das ist nur der Hardware-Hersteller. Das ist... Wie soll ich sagen? Die Kameraabteilung von PleTak hat früher mal so gründig gehört. Daher kenne ich die etwas. Gründig kommt ja auch aus Franken, so wie man meine Sprache anhört. Die sind also in dem Kamerageschäft schon sehr lange in diesem professionellen Überwachungskamera-Bereich. Aber ob die tatsächlich... Also es wäre mir neu, dass PleTak tatsächlich irgendwie so komplette Lösungen und Installationen in Städten anbietet als Dienstleistung. Die bauen einfach Kameras. Punkt. So wie andere Leute Schraubenzieher bauen oder sonst irgendwas.
Okay, also über links und mit ein bisschen googeln findet man da auch Seiten, die dann an ein ominöses Institut an der Uni München auch führen, die da scheinbar was jetzt Bildverarbeitung angeht, die ziemlich weit vorne sind.
Natürlich, man braucht natürlich dann auch die Software hinter. Also gibt es auch schon, um die Leute dann halt automatisch auch zu tracken. Also einfach Gesichter. Also noch Gesichtserkennung selber funktioniert noch nicht. Also hoffentlich jedenfalls nach meinen Informationen. Allerdings, was schon funktioniert, ist einfach Leute, wirklich die werden angeklickt und dann kann man sie, also wenn sie automatisch durch die System verfolgt. Und auch wenn Kameras umgeschaltet werden, dann erkennt er auch automatisch wieder die richtige Person und kann die weiterverfolgen. Und man kann inzwischen auch schon abnormales Verhalten feststellen. Also wenn zum Beispiel, das hatten wir vor ein paar Monaten in der Videoüberwachungs-Chaos-Radio schon, wenn zum Beispiel jemand im Parkhaus auf einmal anfängt, irgendwie wild durch die Gegend zu rennen, dann geht da irgendwie beim Wächter die rote Lampe los, weil er sich halt irgendwie abnormal für den Parkhaus benimmt.
Dass er mal kurz vorm Fernseher wieder auf den Überwachungsmonitor gucken muss. Genau.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang, was ich auch besonders kritisch finde, weil ich mich heute erst auch noch mit unserem Datenschützer gerade über dieses Thema auch unterhalten habe, ist der Hinweis zum Beispiel der S-Bahn Berlin GmbH, dass halt nur kontrollierte Personen halt Zugriff auf die dort gesammelten Bildmaterialien haben. Wenn ich mir das alles so anhöre, wie machtlos die eigentlich auch sind und das auch damit vergleiche, sag ich mal, wie unser Datenschützer halt auch sagt, er ja eigentlich gegen Wände läuft, finde ich das eigentlich auch nicht besonders beruhigend.
Ja, mehr Macht den Datenschützern.
Keine Frage. Mehr Leute, mehr Kohle, das würde auch schon sehr weit helfen. Die sind alle unteraus gestattet, das sowieso und die Mitspracherechte, also sie können natürlich jetzt auch selber aktiv werden. Früher mussten man das erst melden, so ein Datenschutzverstoß, aber die können jetzt auch initiativ werden. Nur das Problem ist, ohne Leute ist das schwierig. Das dauert dann halt sehr lange.
Vielleicht sollten sie mal Sivi stellen.
Ausbilden.
Chris, danke für den Anruf. So, 0371 77 97 110, wie gesagt, die Nummer. Ihr müsst euch jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen fühlen. Auch Gegner sind mal willkommen, weil wir wollen natürlich auch wissen, was für Argumente gibt es eigentlich pro? Uns sind nämlich keine Eingangsweilen. Und da könnt ihr ja auch mal was springen lassen. Ansonsten natürlich, wenn ihr mit Biometrie nicht zufrieden seid, wenn ihr euch denkt, nee, also in meinem Pass möchte ich so was nicht haben und ich sag euch auch gerne weil oder ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass bestimmte Szenarien dann die Folge sind und dass wir in fünf Jahren das oder das haben. Wenn ihr euch Sorgen macht, könnte die auch Kuntu 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer. Können wir irgendwie technisch noch einen Schritt weitergehen? Weil wir haben bestimmt noch was auf der Liste stehen.
Ja, natürlich. Wir wollen ja den Anspruch an die Hörer doch etwas aufrechterhalten. Dann gehe ich jetzt mal weiter. Wir hatten ja für die Hörer, die erst neu dazugestoßen sind, wir hatten uns unterhalten über die ICAO, die International Civil Aviation Organization. Genau, und die MLTDs, die Machine Readable Travel Documents und die Standards, die es dazu gibt und die Empfehlungen innerhalb dieser ICAO. Es geht also um einen kontaktlosen, integrierten Schaltkreis, der in den Ausweis eingebaut wird. Und das wird tatsächlich, also wenn ich hier von Ausweis spreche, dann ist das Synonym für Reisedokumente. Ich rede nicht vom Personalausweis, der ist kein Reisedokument, sondern ein Reisepass, Visas oder auch andere. Es gibt auch andere Dokumente für Leute, die gar keinen Pass haben, dass die dann Reisedokumente, Reiseausweise, Reisepässe ausgestellt bekommen, die aber nicht der Reisepass sind, den der Normalbürger bekommt. So, die bleiben also erstmal so wie sie sind. Also so ein Papiergebinde mit einer einzelnen Plastikkarte drin und einem Pappdeckel Einwand, so wie wir unseren Reisepass eben kennen. So bleibt der, nur dass in diesen Pappdeckel Einwand dieser IC, also dieser Schaltkreis hineinkommt und auch eine Antenne. Nachdem das ja über Funk geht, muss ja bei Funk auch immer eine Antenne involviert sein. Und bei diesen 13, 56 Megahatze, die als Funkfrequenz verwendet werden, für den Standard, ist die Antenne auch relativ lang. Das heißt, man wickelt da ein Stück Draht, wickelt das so auf und diese Wickelung, die wird dann irgendwie in diese Pappe mit eingepresst. Genau, wie eine Spule, ist tatsächlich eine Spule. Diese Technologie, diese gewickelte Antenne und dieser kontaktlose Chip, die gibt es tatsächlich schon. Normalerweise wird das in Plastikkarten eingegeben. Also in so EC-Kartenformat, wie man das kennt. Das EC-Kartenformat ist übrigens in ISO IEC 7816-1 spezifiziert. Die physischen Abmessungen von den entsprechenden Karten. So, ja, in jedem Fall ist das für Plastikkarten gedacht. Und jetzt macht man das in so einen Pappdeckel rein. Und dann, man hat das in der Hosentasche, man setzt sich mal drauf. Und dann ist diese Antenne ja verlötet mit dem Chip. Und dann bricht das vielleicht mal. Und dann geht das auf einmal nicht mehr. Das sind also die Probleme, mit denen man dort kämpft. Es gibt also unendlich viele Probleme in der technischen Detailumsetzung, mit der sich die ICAO oder diese MROTD-Gruppe in der ICAO beschäftigt. Und es gibt also andere Probleme zum Beispiel, dass man ja auch Visas, nicht nur den Reisepass, sondern auch ein Visum elektronisch sein soll. Das ist so, dass in diesem ersten Schritt, das muss ja alles sehr schnell gehen, die Politiker wollen ja morgen gleich am besten diese Ausweise haben, ist es also so, dass dieser Chip nur einmal beschrieben wird von dem Land, das diesen Chip herausgibt. Der deutsche Ausweis hat also so einen Chip und der wird nur einmal von der ausgebenden Stelle beschrieben. Und jetzt ein Visum wird dann nicht elektronisch mit auf den Chip draufgeschrieben von dem indischen Konsulat oder so. Sondern das Visum wird nach wie vor etwas sein, was zusätzlich hinein geklebt wird in den Ausweis. Da ist aber dann auch noch mal ein Chip drin. Das heißt, dass ich bekomme dann auf die Papierseiten bekomme ich wieder ein Stück Papier geklebt, was auch wieder so ein Chip hat und noch mal eine Antenne. Und wenn ich dann zu viele von diesen Chips und solchen Antennen an einer Stelle habe, dann gibt es da Interferenzen und Kollisionen. Und der RESA kann dann nicht mehr genau unterscheiden. Spreche ich jetzt mit dem Visum oder mit dem eigentlichen Ausweischip. Also da gibt es unendlich viele Probleme bei der technischen Umsetzung. Und das jetzt nur mal so an der Stelle. So, was wird jetzt da gespeichert? Ich hatte gesagt, wir haben das Gesicht, also ein Foto, ein digitales Foto, so wie ich es mit der Digitalkamera mache als JPEG-Foto, wird da gespeichert auf der Karte. Von der Auflösung her sollen da ungefähr 90 Pixel, also Wildpunkte zwischen den Augen sein. Es ist also keine so gewaltig große Auflösung. Die kriege ich selbst mit einer uralten, selbst mit der Handy-Kamera kriege ich die hin. Diese Bildqualität. Und man geht davon aus, dass so ein Bild in dieser Größe bei dieser Auflösung ungefähr 20 bis 25 Kilobyte braucht. Das heißt, dieser Chip muss diese Speicherkapazität zur Verfügung stellen. Das ist auch schon wieder ein Problem, dass hier mit größerer Speicherkapazität, und für solche Chips sind 25 Kilobyte tatsächlich schon relativ groß, die natürlich entsprechend teurer werden. Und auch wenn wir jetzt dann über Sicherheitsmerkmale noch sprechen, auch hier, das wird also erheblich teurer. Das ist dann so, dass dieser Chip an und für sich schon mehr kostet, als der Ausweis im Moment insgesamt kostet. Und also hier gibt es dann Kostenfaktoren, die mit reinspielen. Auch wenn ich noch mehr biometrische Merkmale, die als optional definiert sind, mit aufnehme, wie Fingerabdruck, dann habe ich für jeden Fingerabdruck nochmal, ich glaube, 12 Kilobyte oder so rechnen die. Ja, dann kann ich das hoch rechnen. Ihr das, glaube ich, noch mehr. Ich glaube, so 30. Wann war es nicht mehr? Gut, müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachlesen. Ich habe hier den Ordner liegen. Ist auch egal, auf jeden Fall, je mehr. Man stelle sich vor, irgendein Land meint, das muss jetzt hier alle 10 Fingerabdrücke nehmen. Und dann ist natürlich der Speicheraufwand umso größer. Interessant ist also, dass diese ECHO eben sagt, dass das Foto, das Gesicht, das biometrische Merkmal, das international einheitlich zu überprüfen ist. Und andere Länder können auch vereinzelt, wenn sie das wollen, für sich weitere Merkmale machen. Und jetzt die europäischen Innenminister sagen, ja, wir wollen darüber hinaus auch noch den Fingerabdruck haben. Die Amerikaner sowieso. Also diese Dinge, die da alle optional drinstehen, die Einzelländer machen können für sich, wenn sie wollen. Das wird also schon wieder überholt hier von dem politischen Aktionismus, dass das wohl tatsächlich passieren wird. Eine andere interessante Geschichte ist, dass der Standard nicht erfordert, dass es irgendwelche Zugangsbeschränkungen gibt zu den Daten. Das heißt, jeder mit einem ISO 14443-Leser kann gemäß dem Standard diese Daten auslesen.
Ist das nicht verschlüsselt?
Das ist nicht verschlüsselt, nein.
Ach so, gar nicht?
Ja, das ist optional, kann ein Land da passive Authentikation, aktive Authentikation oder vielleicht Verschlüsselung oder irgendwas, was die alle einsetzen, aber von sich aus ist das einfach mal für jeden auslesbar. Das heißt, ich kann mir dann ein kleines Gerät bauen oder so ein Leser an meinen PDA machen und dann laufe ich so hinter den Menschen vorbei, so auf Höhe des Hinterteils, wo sie alle ihre Ausweise drin haben oder auf Höhe der Jackett-Tasche und lese dann mal so aus, was die alle sie in den Ausweisen drin stehen haben. Da gibt es optional die Möglichkeit, dass ein Land in seinen Ausweisen eine Vorkehrung trifft, dass man sozusagen erst diese maschinenlesbare Zeile, also diese OCR-Zeile, auf dem Ausweis selber auslesen muss und daraus sozusagen ein Schlüssel generiert wird, mit dem ich dann die Daten auslesen kann aus dem DIN-ENISO IEC 7816-4-Chip.
Das gefällt dir, ne? Er spricht sogar im Schlaf.
Ja, ein Abkürzungspetitionsschiff. Das ist eine optionale Maßnahme, die einzelne Länder machen können. Aber ein Requirement ist das nicht. Also es muss nicht sein. Und was da jetzt Deutschland machen wird oder nicht, das steht also auch noch in den Sternen. Das Problem oder der Grund, warum man sowas optional macht, zum einen, es gibt Länder, die kümmert Datenschutz nicht. Also die USA, ja. Ich meine, es ist ja bekannt, dass Datenschutz dort faktisch nicht existiert. Dass jeder mit Daten machen kann, was er will. Und da ist es einfach egal. Und ansonsten ist es so, dass in dem Moment, wo ich so eine Authentikation mache, dass das hier mit dem Schlüsselgenerator und OCA-Zeile lesen und dergleichen, dass dann der Chip deutlich teurer wird, weil er nämlich ein sogenannter Prozessor-Chip sein muss. Das heißt, der hat dann einen kleinen Prozessor drin, der dann diese Schlüsselberechnung machen kann und so weiter. Das ist also deutlich mehr, als wenn ich einfach nur einen Speicherchip habe, auf dem was drauf steht, was ich auslesen kann.
Da muss man noch mal irgendwie die Deutschen in Schutz nehmen. Also die deutsche Regierung bzw. die Vertreter Deutschlands waren irgendwie diejenigen, die halt gefordert haben, dass die Verschlüsselung auch, wenn auch nur optional, aber zumindest mit reinkommt. Also vorgesehen war es nicht. Und die Amis haben auch gesagt, ne, wir machen das nicht. Aber da haben sich die Deutschen irgendwie, weil sie halt so ein bisschen wenigstens was auf Datenschutz halten, sich eingemischt und gesagt, also wenigstens, wenn schon, dann...
Also der Sinn, um das vielleicht noch mal deutlich zu machen, der Sinn dieser Sache ist sozusagen, dass ich meinen Ausweis aufklappen muss und dann von einem Scanner erst diese Zeile gelesen wird, die unterste Zeile auf dieser eingeschweißten Seite. Und dann erst danach kann der Leser über Funk kommunizieren, und auslesen aus dem Ausweis. Das heißt, es kann niemand auslesen, solange der Ausweis zugeklappt in meiner Tasche ist.
Aber was passiert denn in den USA? Ich meine, die müssen ja gewährleisten, dass die Technologie trotzdem vorhanden ist. Das heißt, die müssen dann nur für die Deutschen, die dieses System haben, irgendwie diese Auslesegeschichte performen.
Nicht jetzt nur für die Deutschen, aber nachdem es jetzt eben in diesem ICAO Technical Report drinsteht, müssen sämtliche Lesegeräte, müssen darauf ausgelegt sein, diese sogenannte Passive Authentication, also dieses Lesen tatsächlich zu unterstützen.
Das kostet ja im Grunde auch wieder super viel Zeit, oder nicht?
Na, das ist gar nicht der Fall. Es ist auch alles drin beschrieben, wie so ein kombinierter Leser aussieht. Also man klappt einfach den Ausweis auf, sodass der Deckel halt absteht und der Rest vom Ausweis nach unten zeigt. Und dann sieht man das über so ein, man kann sich das vorstellen wie so ein rechte Gegenquader, also wie so ein Backstein oder was, da ziehe ich das einfach drüber. Der Deckel liegt oben auf, die Seite liegt an der Seite an. Ich ziehe das einmal drüber, dann wird gelesen und kommuniziert. Und zumindest laut dem Standard, die Technik gibt das nur eingeschränkt her, aber laut dem Standard soll der komplette Vorgang unter fünf Sekunden dauern.
Warum klappst du jetzt nicht? Warum macht ihr...
Mist, jetzt hab ich mich wieder draufgesetzt. Jetzt ist die Antenne wieder abgeworfen.
Jetzt hab ich wirklich den Backstein genommen. Wie sieht denn der Ausweis jetzt aus?
Wir haben ja das Problem, wie sieht denn der Ausweis aus, wenn die Antenne abgebrochen ist? Ich meine, die RFID-Chips, die müssen ja auch so eingeklebt sein, dass man sie eigentlich nicht abmachen kann.
Richtig, das ist ein weiterer Punkt. Mit so was setzen die sich jetzt in dem Standard natürlich nicht aus. Die sagen einfach, der ist so eingeklebt, dass er tamperproof und wie auch immer man das alles beschreibt.
Was ist, wenn ich ihn in die Mikrowelle lege?
Dann hast du Eigentum der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zerstört.
Ist klar.
Das steht aber dann auch drauf. Sie haben sich mittlerweile auf ein Logo geeinigt, die das aussehen wird. Na, da gibt es drei verschiedene Textvorschläge, die auf dem Ausweis angebracht werden können. Die sagen, das ist ein Sensitive Electronic Device. Und das heißt es genauso, wir handeln wie andere elektronische Geräte. Blablabla.
Und wenn sie es in die Mikrowelle tun, bitte vorher in eine Katze stecken. So, aber wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, Roland, bist du noch am Telefon? Jo, bin ich. Du vertrittst tatsächlich eine andere Meinung. Das finde ich gut, dass du anrufst. Wie sieht dir die Meinung aus?
Ja, ich habe mich einfach ein bisschen gefragt, von wegen, was soll der ganze Spaß eigentlich und warum regt ihr euch da drüber auf? Weil, gut, das Ganze mag Geld kosten. Das mag nicht so wünschenswert sein.
Nicht zu wenig.
Aber, ich meine, letzten Endes, was bringt es jemandem, wenn er weiß, dass ihr blaue Augen habt, dass ihr 1, 80 groß seid, dass ihr irgendwo geboren seid?
Dass er irgendwo wohnt, dass er meine Fingerabdrücke hat, die man kopieren kann, die man an Tatorten hinterlassen kann.
Na ja, aber das wäre jetzt schon ein bisschen arg spekulativ.
Nee, das ist es überhaupt gar nicht. Das ist genau das, was funktioniert.
Das kannst du heutzutage auch so machen. Roland, ist ja schon ein Sprung, ob du nur, wenn du irgendwann mal in deinem Leben in der Nähe von einem Tatort gewesen sein solltest und du bist irgendwie verdächtigt, dann werden dir aus erkennungsdienstlichen Gründen die Fingerabdrücke genommen. Oder einer geht hinten an deinem Arsch vorbei, macht die Beep und hat sie. Das ist ja schon ein anderes Ding, oder?
Also ich meine, wenn einer deinen Fingerabdruck haben will, dann nimmt er sich irgendwas, wo du gerade warst, nimmt sich den Fingerabdruck und transportiert ihn an den Ort, an dem er ihn haben will.
Und der Staat?
Na gut, ich meine dein Vertrauen in den Staat scheint jetzt generell nicht so besonders groß zu sein, oder?
Das mag sein. Ist deins größer?
Okay, und das ist jetzt, ich möchte mal jetzt das hier nicht eskalieren lassen, aber das ist ja okay. Jeder kann meinen Fingerabdruck haben, wenn er jetzt irgendwie die Flasche, die ich gerade angefasst habe, abnimmt und das dann digitalisiert und so weiter. Das ist ja okay, da gibt's einen Aufwand, der dahinter steckt. Es muss also ein wichtiges Interesse irgendwo da sein, dass jemand die Motivation hat, mir hinterherzulaufen, meine Flasche zu nehmen, das abzunehmen, zu digitalisieren und so weiter. Das ist was ganz anderes, als wenn du pauschal von allen Bürgern von vorneherein die Fingerabdrücke nimmst und dann jeden Fingerabdruck, der irgendwo hinterlassen wird, in Deutschland sofort demjenigen zuordnen kann, der da mal irgendwie seine Hand hingelegt hat.
Ja, aber eigentlich ist das doch ganz nett. Ich meine, die gerichtliche Beweislast eines Fingerabdrucks kannst du dadurch doch ziemlich zerstören, oder?
Tja, wenn sie es dann mal machen.
Ja, ich meine, in den USA gab's ja doch schon öfter diese Diskussion um die Zulässigkeit von Fingerabdrücken und von...
Und wie waren die Ergebnisse? Das wird bis jetzt noch nicht angezweifelt. Also bis jetzt ist ein Fingerabdruck irgendwie ein sehr eindeutiges Merkmal.
Also da gab's mehrere, während von 2001, meine ich.
Dass es nicht eindeutig ist, aber von Gerichten wird's heutzutage trotzdem noch als...
Ja, genau, und so wie es Merkmale waren, weil's zu viele Daten waren und so weiter und so fort, weil's nicht so wirklich gestimmt hat, weil mal dreckige Finger im Spiel waren und ähnliches.
Gut, du meinst also deine These ist sozusagen, man sollte Fingerabdruck als biometrisches Merkmal verbreiten, weil dann die Beweiskraft des Fingerabdrucks sozusagen im Zweifelsfall vor Gerichten abnimmt. Ist eine interessante These, finde ich auf jeden Fall einen interessanten Aspekt. Ansonsten, was hast du sonst noch für eine Position zu dem Thema?
Ach Gott, ich meine, das ist ein Geldrausschmiss, aber ich meine, das muss ja niemanden stören. Es wird an anderen Orten auch viel Geld rausgeschmissen.
Das ist aber auch dein Geld, oder? Ja gut, okay, das kommt immer so. Na gut, du wirst auch irgendwie, also Mehrwertsteuer zahlen wir alle zum Beispiel, ja, da kommt keiner drum rum.
Ich meine, wenn der Staat kein Geld hat, dann geht es dir irgendwie auch nicht besser. Also, dann hast du irgendwie einfach mal weniger kulturelle Einrichtungen. Also, das betrifft dich schon direkt, wenn der Staat Geld rausschmeißt. Okay, damit trifft es irgendwie 79.999.000 Leute und genau dich nicht.
Ja, ihr könnt natürlich gegenhalten, wenn ihr möchtet, oder auch noch mitmachen in der Richtung, wenn ihr sagt, der Meinung bin ich aber auch, 0331 77 91 10 ist die Nummer von Fritz. Das Chaosradio auf Fritz Biometrie, das Thema heute Abend, eine Stunde haben wir noch. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen. Wir strecken so ein bisschen den Rücken und werden gleich wieder da sein. 0331 77 91 10 ist die Nummer. Ich bin gespannt, ihr da so in der Sendung habt. Ich bin gespannt ihr da so in Sendung habt. So, beruhigende Klänge hier auch mal im Chaos Radio, damit die Stimmung nicht so hochkommt. Ein Stündchen noch, Thema Biometrie heute Abend im Chaos Radio. Aktueller Anlass ist, dass biometrische Merkmale, habt ihr sicherlich in den Nachrichten mitgekriegt, jetzt in Pässen, Visa und ähnlichen Sachen untergebracht werden sollen, damit das alles nicht unbedingt schneller geht, auch nicht unbedingt einfacher geht, damit es geht einfach. Damit es einfach nur geht. Das ist der Grund. Und was ihr davon haltet, das ist die Frage 0371-97-110. Und am Telefon ist der H-Kon aus Berlin. Hallo, H-Kon.
Ich hab jetzt auch gerade erst eingeschaltet, ich hab aber trotzdem eine Frage. Und zwar weiß ich nicht, wie weit das schon diskutiert worden ist. Wir gehen immer davon aus, oder viele Bürger in diesem Land gehen immer noch davon aus, dass sie geschützt werden, dass ihre Daten geschützt werden. Und wir gehen davon aus, dass es immer jemanden gibt, der darüber wacht. Jetzt frage ich mich aber, was passiert, wenn eben totalitäre Strukturen greifen, wenn eben es keinen Schutz mehr gibt, also eine Gesetzeslücke oder was auch immer. Gerade in Zeiten des Antiterror-Kampfes oder wie auch immer, es gibt ja verschiedene Vorwände, braucht man ja nicht viel dazu, um Daten erfassen zu können. Es ist ja auch kein Geheimnis, dass es möglich ist, Chips auf Entfernung zu erfassen, d.h. auch Wege abzugehen und so weiter. also auch, dass eine Organisation von Wegen innerhalb eines Landes sehr gut nachvollziehbar ist und so weiter und so weiter. Also ich würde eher sagen, man muss es jedem so schwer wie möglich machen, die Daten von Einzelnen zu erfassen, um es auch dem Staat letzten Endes, mit welchen Zielen auch immer da rangeht, ja totalitäre Strukturen aufzubauen. Ich nehme hier nochmal zum Beispiel die Vereinigten Staaten oder wie auch immer.
Gutes Beispiel. Wir hatten ganz am Anfang der Sendung auch mal über das US-Visit Programm, was so schön heißt. Visit, Besuch, ihr seid willkommen womöglich. Aber da hat man genau das, was du beschrieben hast, den Fall, dass die Records von den Passagieren mit den Biometriedaten, mit den Abgleichsdaten von den nationalen Security Agencies in den USA und ganz vielen Datenbanken einfach vernetzt werden über dieses Programm. Und das bedeutet genau, dass wir keine Kontrolle mehr haben. Das heißt aber auch, was wir sagen, wir brauchen für den Datenschutz sowas wie Zweckbindungen. Also die Daten werden für einen bestimmten Zweck erhoben, nämlich dafür, dass man die Identität bezogen auf den Ausweis feststellen kann. Bedeutet dann aber in den USA, wenn die Daten dort abgeglichen werden, dass im Abgleich gleichzeitig mit den Fahndungsdaten stattfindet. Und das können wir von hier aus nur ganz schlecht verhindern. Bei den Flugdaten hat man ja gesehen, zu welchen Konten man da kommt.
Ich will es dir gar nicht so sehr auf ein Land begrenzen. Ich meine die Tendenz, dass totalitäre Strukturen einmal starken sind und dass es dem Staat immer leichter gemacht wird, Daten über seine Börse zu sammeln. Oder auch, dass sich viele Leute einfach breit quatschen lassen über Bonusprogramme, Bonus-Main-Programme und so weiter, freiwillig Daten preiszugeben und damit eben auch Wege verfolgbar werden, damit auch Einstellungen genauer kontrolliert werden können.
Da hilft wirklich nur Aufklärung. Das heißt, man muss sich immer in seinem Freundeskreis immer erzählen, welche Folgen das hat und es sozusagen so plastisch wie möglich machen, dass man dann spürt, was das bedeutet, wenn man seine Kontrolle über die Daten verliert.
Oder jedes Mal, wenn die Frau vorne in der Kasse irgendwie ihre Kundenkarte rauszieht, dann irgendwie groß, ah, sie hat eine Kundenkarte, sind sie ein wahnsinnig und also man kann auch schon ein bisschen was machen.
Ja, wie auch immer, also was mir halt ein bisschen fehlt bei der ganzen Datendiskussion, auch wenn ich das auf anderen Sender höre, ist, dass man eben immer von einem Jetzt-Stand ausgeht. Das ist ja eigentlich ein relativ friedlicher Umgang anscheinend herrscht mit Daten, mit Personbezugenden Daten. Ich glaube aber, viel wichtiger ist es eben auch daran zu denken, was passiert gerade, totalitäre Strukturen, was kann dann mit solchen Daten geschehen. Das gibt es in diesem Land, weiß ich nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt, aber es gab mal ein Recht auf Widerstand des Einzelnen, wenn demokratische Strukturen verloren gehen oder wenn demokratische Strukturen in Gefahr sind, wie weit kann sich der Einzelne überhaupt noch zu wehrsetzen, wenn überhaupt schon klar ist, wo er sich bewegt, was passiert und so weiter. Das heißt also auch die Berechenbarkeit von Zuständen, Umständen, von wie auch immer wird berechenbarer. Ich will es nicht zu sehr an die Wand malen, aber ich glaube...
Das ist keine Schwarzmalerei.
darüber nachzudenken, was in Zukunft mit unseren Daten passiert. Es ist nämlich nicht gesagt, dass die demokratischen Strukturen, so wie sie jetzt bestehen, auch bestehen bleiben. Und deshalb glaube ich, ist es wichtig, darüber sich Gedanken zu machen, was passiert mit meinen Daten, was geschieht mit den Daten meiner Kinder und so weiter und so weiter und wie weit will ich den Vorschub leisten. Und ich glaube, man muss es jedem Staat, egal zu welcher Zeit und egal zu welchem Weg, immer schwer machen, Daten von Bürgergruppen oder einzelnen Bürgern zu bekommen. Nicht um schlechten, einfach nur um zu sehen, es ist wichtig, dass wir eine gewisse Anonymität gewährleisten, dass auch jeder Mensch eine Privatsphäre hat, die niemand berühren darf und auch eine Gedankenfreiheit herrscht, die niemand berühren darf.
Das ist der Grundsatz der Datensparsamkeit, wenn man sich so die Aufgaben und die Ziele des Datenschutzes im Allgemeinen anschaut, dann findet man eben genau diese Dinge und das bezieht sich auch nicht nur auf den Staat, sondern genauso auf Privatwirtschaft oder auf jegwegliche Organisationen. Daten sollten nie irgendwo anfallen und gesammelt werden und so weiter. Es muss eigentlich jedes System von vornherein so entwickelt werden, dass es datensparsam ist. Und das ginge selbst bei Biometrien, Ausweisdokumenten. Gäbe es denkbare technische Möglichkeiten, hier datensparsam zu arbeiten, aber dazu später mehr?
Ja, halte ich immer noch so gefährlich, weil dann die Tendenz zur Überwachung natürlich gegeben ist. Sogenannte Fernscans sind eben auch möglich. Es lässt sich sehr genau checken, wer wann wo wie lang.
Nein, eben musst du auf eine Insel ziehen und irgendwie die ganze Isolation hinter dir lassen.
Nein, ich glaube, wie wichtig ist, wenn sich jemand darüber klar ist, was er eigentlich mit initialisiert, mit bezahlt, was er dann möglicherweise an seiner Freiheit auch verliert.
Du kannst aber, vielleicht jetzt um dieses Beispiel mal an der Stelle noch aufzugreifen, ich weiß nicht, ob wir später noch Zeit haben oder dazukommen. Man könnte sich schon ein System vorstellen, wo die gesamte Datenverarbeitung und die Überprüfung sozusagen auf dem Ausweis gemacht wird. Das ist natürlich viel aufwendiger und viel intensiver. Also der Chip müsste sehr viel intelligenter und aufwendiger sein. Aber das sozusagen nur die Kameradaten oder die Daten, das Fingerabdruck, lasers innen, wenn du an der Grenze bist, werden übertragen in deinen Reiseausweis hinein. Und der Reiseausweis vergleicht dann innen drin die Daten mit den von dir ursprünglich erfassten Daten und trifft dann danach eben Entscheidungen. Das Ganze noch in einem sicheren und verifizierten, authentisierten Zustand. Das heißt ja, die Fingerabdruckdaten werden nie irgendwo anders gespeichert, außer in deinem Ausweis. Und es gibt gar keine Möglichkeit, die auszulesen. Technisch ist sowas denkbar.
Wir müssen dann aber trotzdem zusätzlich noch verhindern, dass wir an dem Gerät, wo wir das dann sozusagen am Kontrollpunkt dann machen, dass dieses Gerät nicht auch wieder sozusagen eine Leitung nach außen hat.
Richtig, aber ich sage es gäbe...
Nehmen wir an, ich verreise. Oder will mit meiner Freundin zusammen verreisen, ja? Nun wird an der Grenze... Bitte meine Freundin, doch bitte meinen Auslass mitzubringen. Nun wird dann an der Grenze kontrolliert. Sie hat noch beide Auslasspapiere, wie auch immer. Die biometrischen Daten werden abgeglichen, abgescannt, wie auch immer. Und schon sitzen wir in einer Sicherheitsfalle. So, das heißt also, zumindest, wenn wir erst mal registriert. Merkwürdig, oder? Würden wir erst mal registriert, nicht werden, würden wir. Nein. Wenn der Ausweisträger mit den biometrischen Merkmalen des Ausweishalters verglichen wird. Und wenn wir an meine Freundin hatten, meine Ausweistapiere. Muss ja niemand wissen. Schon sitzen wir in einer Sicherheitsfalle.
Wieso? Ich verstehe nicht ganz.
Na, ein Beispiel. Ich bitte meine Freundin oder mein Freund, oder wie auch immer, mein Ausweis mitzunehmen. Der gerät in eine Sicherheitsschleuse. Ich befinde mich an Punkt A, als ich an Punkt B. Wir wollen uns an Punkt A treffen. Möglicherweise irgendwo außerhalb irgendeiner Grenze oder irgendeines Sicherheitsbereichs. Der hat aber mein Ausweis dabei und seinen eigenen auch noch. Das heißt, er hat zwei Auslöse von Tieren, seines eigenen und meinen.
Warum hat er deinen Ausweis denn?
Wie bitte?
Warum hat er deinen Ausweis? Ich meine, dann würde jeder Beamte sagen, dass du das Ding nicht... Ja, aber dann würde natürlich jeder sagen, dass du deinen Ausweis nicht weitergeben darfst.
Das passiert dir jetzt auch schon, wenn du jetzt irgendwo in der Sicherheitszone bist und jemand anderes hat deinen Ausweis mitgenommen, das hat mit biometriert nichts zu tun.
Aber da kann ich immer noch mit jemandem verhandeln. Aber wenn irgendein Sicherheitscomputer irgendwo sitzt, der wird natürlich erstmal Action machen. Es geht mir auch gar nicht so sehr darum. Es geht mir einfach um die Gefahren totalitärer Strukturen.
Die sind da noch.
Das ist schon wichtig.
Okay, nehmen wir so mit.
Sehr gefährlich.
Der Lasse aus Husum, hallo Lasse.
Ja, mir geht es darum, also den der vor mir hier dran war, dem verstehe ich schon recht gut, was er meint. Und mir geht es ähnlich, also es geht mir darum, dass nicht mein Fingerabdruck einfach so erfasst wird und dann abrufbar ist, sondern wenn es einen Grund gibt, dann können sie mich ja direkt fragen, ob ich meinen Finger irgendwo raufdrücke.
Also, das ist auch eine ganz fundamentale Forderung von unserer Seite.
Ja, und dass nicht halt irgendwelche Gesichtsdaten von mir erfasst werden und dort dann immer abrufbar sind. Wobei ich mich auch frage, wie wollen sie diese biometrischen Daten vergleichen? Ich meine, es gibt ja die Verbrecherkarteien, halt die Daten, die erfasst worden sind und dann meine Daten im Ausweis, wobei ich jetzt nicht voraussetzen will, dass ich in der Verbrecherkartei stehe.
Also, das sollte eigentlich nicht erlaubt sein. Also, falls sie wirklich die Fingerabdrücke abnehmen, um sie in Pässe und Personalespeisen zu speichern, sollte es eigentlich so sein, dass sie nicht gleichzeitig mit den Verbrecherkarteien abgeglichen werden dürfen.
Ja, das ist aber nur unter engen Bedingungen. Also, hier in Deutschland können wir sagen, dass so ein Verfahren nicht verhältnismäßig ist. Aber was de facto in den USA jetzt gerade passiert mit US-Weset ist genau das.
Aber ich glaube, worauf unser Zuhörer eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, wie denn dieser Vergleich oder was auch immer an der Grenze passiert, stattfinden. Was du an der Grenze machen willst, ist nicht abgleichen, oder eigentlich in der Regel nicht abgleichen mit Verbrechern, sondern du willst eigentlich nur feststellen, ob diese Person tatsächlich die Person ist, die sie ist, und ob sie einen gültigen Ausweis hat und ob der Ausweis tatsächlich ein nicht gefälschter, originär von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ausgestellter Ausweis ist. Du willst also jetzt nicht anfangen, bei jedem, der einreist, irgendwie zu vergleichen gegen zentrale Verbrecherkarteien.
Personen, die wie sie aussehen, haben auch mal versucht, einen Anschlag auf ein Flugzeug zu verüben.
Also diese Abgleichfunktion, die spielt dann beim Migrationsmanagement tatsächlich eine Rolle, dass man sagt, okay, es kommt jemand zum Beispiel ohne Papiere an die Grenze. Und wir wollen feststellen, ob der schon mal eingereist ist. Dafür sind solche Identifikations- also solche Vergleiche mit den Datenbanken auch noch ein mögliches Mittel. Also das ist eine der Begründungen, warum sie überhaupt überlegen, mit Datenbanken zu arbeiten. Für diese Grenzkontrollfunktion, also die Verifikation, um das festzustellen, was du beschrieben hast, dazu braucht man diese Datenbanken überhaupt nicht.
Aber Sekunde mal, jetzt mal meine Frage. Worum es da ging, ist ja zum Beispiel Terroristen bemühen sich ja, möglichst normal zu sein heutzutage. Sie versuchen, wirklich so normal als möglich zu sein, weil sie dann eben halt in keines von diesen Rastern passen. Es sind halt eben keine Typen, die in der Tiefgarage irgendwie wild rumrennen, sondern das sind Typen, die gehen in der Tiefgarage so, die üben dann so zu gehen, wie jeder in der Tiefgarage geht. Also versucht man natürlich, so viel Merkmaler als möglich zu sammeln, dass ich weiß, wenn jemand abweicht von seinem üblichen Muster, dann ist irgendwas anders. Das ist doch das, was sie wollen. Ansonsten können sie mit dem Ding doch überhaupt nichts anfangen.
Ja gut, aber dann ist mit dir die Frage, was ist denn sozusagen das normale Verhalten?
Ich meine, die würden Standard sammeln, die würden dich immer wieder kontrollieren. Du hast immer Cordon Bleu gegessen.
Warum nimmt der jetzt Salat?
Also ich meine, das ist doch das, was sie im Endeffekt machen möchten. Oder warum sitzt sie jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr in der ersten Klasse?
Damit fällt man noch keiner Terroristen raus. Also ich meine mal, ehrlich.
Das kommt natürlich dazu, aber das wissen die ja offensichtlich nicht.
Vor allem, also ich meine, das System, das muss ich sagen, das kann man ja auch dann von daher irgendwie ad absurdum führen, indem man einfach versucht, möglichst unsinnige Dinge zu machen, zum Beispiel, dass man einfach Leute auffordert, sie sollen noch alle mal hüpfen in der Tiefgarage. Und dann, wenn irgendwann mal, sei es nur ein Prozent oder wie auch immer, der Leute hüpfen anfangen in der Tiefgarage, dann guckt er irgendwann auch nicht mehr auf seinen roten Knochen vom Monitor.
Ja, aber ich meine, also was ich mir vorstelle, ist, dass gerade so Amerika oder so, denen geht es nicht darum, die Leute vorher zu erwischen, sondern denen geht es darum, um dann den Erfolg ihrer Geheimdienste, zum Beispiel, zu beweisen, möglichst hohe Nachvollziehbarkeit des Weges da sein sollen. Da wissen die halt ganz genau, wo der überall gewesen ist und können dann sagen, ja, der kam aus Deutschland, Deutschland ist doof, danke. So, also das ist es ja auch im Grunde. Also was anderes können sie doch gar nicht gewährleisten.
Ja, und dann im Nachhinein eben nachzuvollziehen, mit wem hatte der Kontakt, wann und was weiß ich und diese ganzen Sachen.
Ja, deswegen ist ja auch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung so wichtig. Dass man das immer noch drei Jahre rückverfolgen kann, zum Beispiel.
Lasse, war es das von deiner Seite?
Das war so ungefähr von meiner Seite. Eine kleine Frage wäre noch, wie wollen die nun überprüfen, dass ich auch wirklich der bin, der im Ausweis steht. Dann müssten wir eigentlich jedes Mal mein Fingerabdruck noch abnehmen. Und dann die mit dem Ausweis vergleichen.
Also es geht, dass das Verfahren sieht irgendwie grob so aus, dass du einmal, wenn du den Ausweis bzw. den Pass beantragst, gehst du zur Meldestelle, legst da dein Finger auf den Sensor. Die speichern das Bild deines Fingers in dem Pass. Und jedes Mal, wenn du über die Grenze willst, musst du dein Finger auflegen. Dein Pass wird gelesen, also der Fingerabdruck aus dem Pass wird gelesen und wird gegen den Fingerabdruck auf dem aktuellen Sensor, also dein Livebild vom Finger wird dagegen verglichen.
Genau. Das ist also der Vorgang. Analog dazu eben auch mit Gesichtserkennung oder mit Iris oder was auch immer. Das ist der gleiche Vorgang, der hier passiert. Und dann gibt es noch eine Frage, die letztendlich zu klären ist, ist dann, wie mache ich das mit der Fälschungssicherheit? Oder wie gewährleiste ich, dass der digitale Fingerabdruck, der in einem Ausweis steht, auch wirklich der ist, der irgendwann mal von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder von der Meldestelle oder von wem auch immer, von der passausgebenden Stelle dort abgespeichert wurde. Das ist dann jetzt so unser nächstes Kapitel, das ich möglichst schnell hinter mich bringe. Vielleicht haben wir noch Hörer oder war das irgendwas?
Lasse es noch da, Lasse es, mach's gut. Und vielleicht eben noch kurz in Hannover aus Stuttgart, weil Stuttgart, hallo, hallo Stuttgart.
Hallo.
Tagchen.
Ich hatte erstmal eine technische Frage, und zwar habt ihr vorher gesagt, bei diesen Verschlüsselungsgeschichten, also wenn die Daten verschlüsselt sind, dass dann niemand darauf zugreifen kann, ohne diesen Schlüssel eben zu haben, den der auf Papier steht.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, also niemand ist natürlich auch wieder mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Also niemand heißt in dem Fall wirklich niemand, oder?
Nein, nicht wirklich niemand. Also ich meine, das ist einfach daher, dass der Schlüssel halt nur bestimmt Länge hat, kann halt jeder irgendwie sich beliebig viele Schlüssel generieren, und irgendwann ist der Schlüssel auch dabei, der dann passt. Aber die Chancen sind natürlich deutlich geringer, als wenn man gar keine Verschlüssel benutzen würde.
Also es ist wie bei jedem Verschlüsselungsverfahren so, dass ein Schlüssel irgendwie eine Länge hat, oder kannst du anfangen wie beim Fahrradschloss, wenn das irgendwie drei Ziffern hat, dann kann man halt schnell diese 1000 Möglichkeiten, die dieses Fahrradschloss hat, ausprobieren, und irgendwann hat man es offen.
Die Frage ist, ist dieser Schlüssel nur in dem Ausweis drin, oder wird der bei der Meldestelle, wo auch immer noch aufbewahrt?
Das ist komplizierter. Da müsste man jetzt wirklich in die Kryptographie einsteigen. Was da verwendet wird, sind sogenannte Public Key Kryptographie, solche Verschlüsselungsverfahren. Das führt jetzt zu weit an der Stelle, und da können wir nicht in die Tiefe einsteigen. Aber es ist so, dass hier tatsächlich State-of-the-Art-Algorithmen und Verfahren verwendet werden.
Wenn man den sowieso nur lesen kann, wenn man vom Papier irgendwas ablässt, dann könnte man ja gleich einen Tipp machen, den man nur über Kontakt auslesen kann.
Das hat mir vorhin irgendwie kurz schon mal hier intern gehabt. Die Frage ist einfach so, dass die Chips in die aktuellen Pässe eingebracht werden. Also es ist halt so angedacht, dass die RFID-Karte in diesen Pappdeckel eingebracht wird. Und da können sie halt wirklich nur kontaktlos machen. Man kann ja irgendwie den Pass nicht in der Form jetzt mit einem kontaktverhafteten Chip ausstatten.
Also es ist einfach so, dass die kontaktbasierte Chipkarten wie die Telefonkarte oder Handykarten, diese GSM-Karten und so weiter, die haben bestimmte Abmessungen, damit sie in den Laser passen und so weiter. Und es muss auch Plastik sein, sonst hält das das gar nicht aus, diese oft, diese Kontaktierungsvorgänge und dergleichen. Das ist immer ein Grund, man kann das nicht sofort umstellen, sondern man muss das als Transition-Mechanismus in diesen Papierausweis einbringen.
Und Stempeln war auch noch ein Argument.
Stempeln ist, ja ja, man muss sicherstellen, dass das nie unter dem Stempeln liegt beim Stempeln und so weiter. Das kann man in diesen Vorschriften nachlesen, aber das führt zu weit. Es ist einfach so, dass der eine Grund, der andere Grund ist, dass es ein optionales Merkmal ist, das mit dieser passiven Authentikation und mit dem Auslesen dieser Papierseite, dieser Maschinenlesbahnzone. Das heißt also, die Amerikaner oder wer auch immer, die machen das einfach nicht und müssen das auch nicht machen. Und da kann es jeder über Funk auslesen. Für die ist das ein Feature. Für uns sieht das vielleicht irgendwie fragwürdig aus.
Ja, also ich denke, das ist ein ganz entscheidender Punkt. Nicht nur, dass eben biometrische Merkmale gespeichert werden, sondern dass eben jeder mit so einem Chip darum läuft, über den er authentifizierbar ist. Was halt so Überlegungen, dass zum Beispiel dann sehr viel einfacher feststellbar ist, wer auf irgendwelchen Demonstrationen rumläuft?
Na ja, du läufst nicht mit einem Reisepass auf Demonstrationen rum.
Man hat schon irgendwie einen gewissen Abstand, wo es funktioniert. Also man sagt so, die Regel ist 10 cm bei den Chips, die dort eingesetzt werden. Das heißt, man müsste dann schon wirklich in dem Pulk mit rumrennen. Und halt wie gesagt, die Kommunikation findet erst statt, wenn diese Maschinen-Dispare zone bekannt ist und irgendwie vorher sollte der Chip eigentlich nichts finden.
Ja, also da denke ich, habe ich jetzt keine Bedenken, dass das so wie es in Deutschland umgesetzt werden soll, dass wir hier eine Schwachstelle haben, halte ich für relativ unproblematisch. Und wie gesagt, es ist jetzt im Moment geht es um Reisepässe. Und Reisepass habe ich innerhalb Deutschlands eigentlich immer in meiner Schublade liegen, den habe ich nur irgendwo dabei, den brauche ich auch nicht innerhalb Deutschlands.
Ja, okay, also für Personalausweise ist da konkret dann noch nichts geplant oder?
Noch nichts geplant.
Also ist auch nirgendwo angesprochen worden, sicherlich ist das irgendwann die logische Schlussfolgerung.
Na doch angesprochen wurde es schon.
Also sagen wir mal so, unser Innenminister hat schon Vorstellungen geäußert, dass wir solche biometrischen Ausweise, wo wir jetzt dann die Personalausweise nutzen könnten, zum Beispiel für E-Commerce zur Abrechnung von Dienstleistungen, also im E-Government Bereich und solche Sachen. Und auch beim Planungsabgleich ist das natürlich schon wichtig, dass wir das auch in Personalausweisen haben.
Dann können die Gesundheitskarte und der biometrische Reisepass um die Wette laufen und die Shopcard. Es gibt auch Karten für Professionelle im Gesundheitswesen. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie das dann die Fachbezahlung heißt. Also es gibt alles mögliche Tolle.
Für Professionelle?
Also ich komm da. Dann machen wir noch mal eine Extra-Sendung, wie geradezu zur Gesundheitskarte, Ärztekarte.
Also ich denke, die werden jetzt erst mal genügend technische Schwierigkeiten für die nächsten paar Jahre mit ihren digitalen Reisepässen haben. Und bis es dann mal zum Personalausweis kommt, wer weiß, wie dann überhaupt alles aussieht.
Ich mein, was halt schon sehr real ist, ist, dass an den meisten Unis inzwischen Studentenausweise mit kontaktlosen Chips ausgegeben werden.
An der TU nicht mehr, da haben sie das Projekt eingestellt.
Ach ja, was ich im Übrigen noch zu diesem Überfunk auslesen und so weiter. Die ICAO selber empfiehlt zum Beispiel für Staaten, die dort Bedenken haben in ihrem Technical Report. Die Leute sollen einfach irgendwie ganz oben und ganz unten in den Ausweis ein bisschen Alufolie mit in den Pappdeckel reinmachen. Also sozusagen solange du den Ausweis nicht aufklappst, sowieso keine Funksignale durch... Alu ist schlecht, schuldigung. Alu ist von wegen... Was war es, paramagnetisch oder diamagnetisch? Ich verwechsel dir immer.
Oder so eine dünne Platinschicht, wer Geld hat.
Oder ein Etui für deinen Ausweis, so ein dünnes Edelstahl-Etui, wo du deinen Ausweis hineinschieben kannst, wer weiß, was hast du da so. Schön. Also das gibt's schon auch noch.
Wenn ich die ganzen Karten in meinem Geldbeutel hab, die kontaktlos ausläsbar sind für jeden Edelstahl-Etui, dann wird mein Geldbeutel schwer.
Dann nimm halt einfach einen Safe mit, ey.
Nimmst einfach so eine Art in der Größe einer Zigarettenschachtel und da steckst du die Karten alle rein. Aus Metall. Und dann hast du die Sache auch wieder erledigt.
So, du wolltest dich irgendwas durchreiten, hast du gesagt.
Ja, ganz kurz. Ich würde mich wirklich sehr kurz fassen.
Ganz kurz kannst du irgendwie dann bei der Gesundheitskartensendung noch mal machen.
Da kann ich es detaillierter machen, genau. Wir machen es ganz kurz nur. Die Frage, die ich ja aufgeworfen habe beim vorletzten Hörer, ist, wie garantiere ich denn, dass der digitale, also dass die digitale biometrische Information, wie der Fingerabdruck, das Gesichtsfoto, was auch immer, in dem Ausweis drin steht, dass es auch tatsächlich das offizielle Foto ist, das bei der Passausstellung dort eingebracht wurde im Chip. Ich könnte einfach den Chip austauschen und dann ist ein anderes Foto drin. Dazu verwendet man also hier sogenannte digitale Zertifikate. Sowas kennt man vielleicht aus dem Internet schon mal. Irgendwann hat man bestimmt die Meldung vom Browser bekommen, ob man dieses Zertifikat akzeptieren will, ob das irgendwie vertrauenswürdig wäre, was auch immer. Das war tatsächlich genau die gleiche Technologie. Wird hier empfohlen von der ICHO. Es sind also sogenannte x509 Zertifikate, die hier verwendet werden. Moment. DER-Encoding. Distinguished Encoding Rules. Die hier zum Einsatz kommen. Ich will jetzt noch nicht weiter in die Abkürzungen reingehen. Es gibt dann so Dinge wie KPUCSCA und KPRDS. Ich hab mir extra die Seite aufgeschlagen. Also es ist dann so, dass mit einer digitalen Unterschrift versehen, das heißt jedes Land hat dann eine Art eine Signatur-Schlüssel, mit dem werden dann die Ausweise unterschrieben. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen komplex, aber man kann sich einfach vorstellen, Deutschland hat jetzt so einen Schlüssel, und mit diesem Schlüssel wird jeder Ausweis unterschrieben.
Jeder immer mit dem Schlüssel.
In der Realität sieht das anders aus. Da gibt es dann nochmal bestimmte Stufen dazwischen. Aber jetzt abstrahiert kann man sich das eben so vorstellen, dass Deutschland einen Schlüssel hat, mit dem man die Ausweise unterschrieben. Und dieser Schlüssel ist auch wieder so ein asymmetrisches Schlüssel oder Public Key Verfahren. Das heißt, es gibt da zwei Teile davon. Einen davon kann man veröffentlichen und einer bleibt privat. Und dieser öffentliche Teil, der muss dann an allen Grenzkontrollstellen in allen Ländern sein, damit das überprüft werden kann. Das heißt, von Deutschland, von den USA, von dem Freitag usw. Jeder, der dann solche biometrischen Pässe hat mit diesen 7816-4-Chips, muss dann von jedem Land der Schlüssel zur Verifikation vorhanden sein. Das heißt, so ein Lesegerät hat dann, wie viele Länder haben wir? 180 und in Dreh muss also 180 mindestens, in der Realität ist es noch viel mehr, Schlüssel vorrätig haben, damit dann überprüft werden kann, ob dieser Ausweis ein echter ist. Und diese Zertifikate bzw. diese Schlüssel, die sollen entsprechend auch im Internet veröffentlicht werden. Das heißt, jeder Mensch der Welt, gesetztenfalls, er hat so einen Lese, den kann man kaufen für 100 Euro jetzt schon. Und die entsprechende Software kann dann überprüfen, ob ein Ausweis tatsächlich ein echter Ausweis ist, um somit sozusagen zu sagen, ob mir die Bundesrepublik Deutschland garantiert, dass dieser Mensch tatsächlich der ist, der behauptet zu sein. Das also kurz zu dem, was hier betrieben wird. Und da ist auch schon ein ganz fundamentales Risiko, sollte nämlich dieser Schlüssel, den die Bundesrepublik Deutschland zum Signieren verwendet, tatsächlich mal irgendwann an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen. Ich meine, der muss ja benutzt werden, um zu signieren. Den brauch ich ja dort. Und wenn dort irgendwo ein Lack ist, wenn dort mal der Schlüssel kopiert wird oder wenn da irgendwas passiert, dann kann jemand anders natürlich Ausweise signieren. Dann kann ich jetzt einen Ausweis fälschen, kann den signieren, und damit wird er überall wunderbar akzeptiert, weil ich ja dann die Bundesrepublik Deutschland war. Und für dieses Szenario, dass der sogenannte, dass die Country Signing CA, dass dieser Schlüssel tatsächlich mal irgendwo in falsche Hände gerät oder öffentlich wird, das wird also auch in diesen ICHO Standards irgendwo so ein bisschen ernannt. Das ist also irgendwie so, ja, dann müsste man halt alle Ausweise neu ausstellen in dem Land und die Alten würden halt alle dann ungültig innerhalb 48 Stunden. Und das wäre also impraktikabel und man solle halt irgendwie dafür sorgen. Also das ist eines der Risiken, die wir hier haben.
Ja, das sieht also prickelnd aus für die Zukunft, was da alles noch auf uns zukommt. 0373 971 110, nur die Nummer noch. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stündchen Zeit. Was mich aber noch interessiert ist zum Beispiel, wird irgendwie gewährleistet in dieser so und so Organisation IKO, oder wie die heißt, was andere Länder mit den Daten machen, die sie da einfach so auslesen können. Also wenn ich irgendwo einreise und die sind irgendwie interessiert, da dran zu speichern, was ich das letzte Mal in dem Land gemacht habe, wo ich hin wollte, was ich machen wollte, dann können die im Grunde alles in der Datenbank speichern. Da kann man mir hier sagen, das ist egal, das wird in Deutschland nicht passieren, woanders kann es im Grunde passieren.
Also diese schaffen Datenbanken, die dann beim Auslesen dieser Merkmale möglich sind. Also wenn man die Geräte nicht so baut, dass sie so abgeschottet sind, dass auch ganz sicher ist, dass man da keine Daten rausholen kann.
Das ist auch bewusst ein Feature. Also man soll dann tatsächlich auch mit seinem maschinenlesbaren Ausweis irgendwie in die Videothek gehen können oder in die Stadtbibliothek und sich dort dann sozusagen authentisieren.
Das heißt, die Bibliotheken kriegen auch das System?
Nein, das ist ein theoretisches Feature, was die die Industrie, die das verkaufen will, irgendwie auch mit mit nennt.
Ich trau meinen Bibliotheken nicht, die haben da Bücher.
Es gibt auch Bibliotheken, wo man auch mit Fingerabdruck sich die Videos auswählen kann. Das heißt, man geht dahin, kriegt eine Chipkarte, kriegt interessanterweise auch einen Pin dazu. Sie haben ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Die Pin ist allerdings standardmäßig auf den Geburtstag eingestellt und gibt dann halt irgendwie seinen Fingerabdruck ab und kann dann halt mit dem Fingerabdruck zu jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit das System benutzen und sich dann irgendwie die dreckigsten Porno-Videos ausleihen, ohne dass der Verleiher irgendwie komisch guckt.
Ja, es ist aber in dem Fall glaube ich kein Fingerabdruck, sondern ein theramischer Print von dem Finger oder so.
Nein, es ist ein optischer Fingerabdruck. Also zumindestens bei den Systemen, die irgendwie in Berlin die Runde machen. Also es ist irgendwie so ein Franchise-Geschichte. Also es gibt irgendwie mehrere deutschen Städte und die machen optisch.
Dann 102, 6.
Null Uhr, 30. Mit dem Wetter, nachts bleibt es meist trocken. Später kann sich Nebel bilden. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 8 bis 4 Grad. Morgens ist es anfangs neblig, trübt mit so ein bisschen Regen. Später die Sonne, Gott sei Dank. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 12 bis 14 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Palästinenser Präsident Arafat ist ernsthaft krank. Ein Regierungsmitglied, sagte Arafat Schwäb in Lebensgefahr. Nach israelischen Angaben soll er das Bewusstsein verloren haben. Die palästinensische Führung hat sich in Arafats Hauptquartieren Ramallah im Westjordanland versammelt. Im Streit um die neue EU-Kommission hat das Europaparlament den Machtkampf gewonnen. Der künftige Präsident Barroso zog noch vor der Abstimmung sein komplettes Team zurück. Viele Europaparlamentarier waren mit mehreren der aufgestellten Kommissaren nicht einverstanden. In Afghanistan sind offenbar Gefangene von US-Soldaten noch brutaler gefoltert worden als im Irak. Das berichtet das ARD Politmagazin Kontraste. Ehemalige Gefangene schildern dort die sexuellen Misshandlungen durch US-Soldaten. Missbrauch und Gewaltexzesse sollen demnach an der Tagesordnung gewesen sein. Die Ergebnisse der ersten Fußball Bundesliga Stuttgart unterliegt Bremen 1 zu 2, Nürnberg verliert gegen Schalke 0 zu 2, Mainz schlägt Rostock 3 zu 1, Hamburg besiegt Freiburg 4 zu 0 und Leverkusen schlägt Bielefeld 3 zu 2. Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft bestreitet am 9. Juni 2006 in München das Eröffnungsspiel der Weltmeisterschaft. Das legte der Fußball-Weltverband am Abend in Frankfurt am Main fest. Die erste Gegner wird am 9. Dezember 2005 in Leipzig ausgelost. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit einer Nachtbauarbeit. Meldung, Autobahn 111. Das ist der Autobahn-Zubringer Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Waldmann-Schlüster-Damm und Kurt-Schuhmacher-Damm. Vollsperrung in der Nacht bis morgens um 5.
So klang Musikunterricht früher. So klingt Musikunterricht heute. Und so klingt Musikunterricht mit Fritz. Denn Fritz und die Modern Music School Berlin kommen in eure Klasse und machen Spezialunterricht im Fach Dreiste Musik mit den Fritz Soundgarden-Moderatoren und Musikexperten Paul van Dyck, Jakob Kranz, Olli Massif, Andre Langenfeld und Radio-Fritze Stefan Michmer. Dazu die Modern Music School Berlin mit professionellem Musik-Equipment. Erfahrt zur Abwechslung mal etwas über Musik, die euch wirklich interessiert und beginnt selbst Musik zu machen. Gewinnt eine Unterrichtsstunde, dreiste Musik. Alles, was ihr dazu braucht, findet ihr unter fritz.de und im Radio.
Ah, der ist hier wunderbar. Die Chaosradio-Jungs sind echt, die haben es drauf. Alles live gewesen hier. Wir können ja auch musikalisch unterhalten. Chaosradio auf Fritz, knapp 30 Minuten noch. Wir reden über Biometrie heute Abend. Harald, der Peter, Starbuck und meine Person der Max. Wirklich ein Thema, was Krass Resonanz hervorruft, was eigentlich immer so ist. Redet keiner drüber, keiner weiß, was Biometrie ist. Chaosradio wird darüber gemacht, über das Thema. Und zack, leuchtet der Telefon auf. Wusstet ihr gar nicht, für die Scheiße. Ja, genauso sollt ihr das wirklich euren Bekannten weiter erzählen. Das haben wir heute Abend mehrfach erzählt. Das läuft, glaube ich, nur so über private Kontakte.
Da können wir vielleicht gleich mal auf den Chaos Communication Congress hinweisen. Und zwar vom 27. bis 29. Dezember. Also wie jedes Jahr zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr gibt es im Haus des Lehrers am Alex den Chaos Communication Congress, also die Veranstaltung, das Chaos Computer Club, die jährliche. Und ihr seid alle dazu herzlich eingeladen. Es gibt da irgendwie tolle Vorträge, Unternahmen auch zu Biometrie.
Infos gibt es natürlich, zumindest den Link auf die Webseite für den Kongress über www.ccc.de. Da findet ihr alle wichtigen Links, für den Fall, dass er nochmal nachlesen möchte, was denn konkret passiert. Aber momentan wird noch gesprochen hier bei uns zwischen dieses Radio und die Frage bei diesen ganzen biometrischen Pässen, Ausweisen, Visa, ist immer noch die des Datenschutzes.
Ja, ich würde das Thema ein bisschen weiterfassen wollen.
Sehkündig, bevor du es weiterfasst, komme ich eben zu dir rüber.
Okay, ich würde das ein bisschen weiterfassen wollen. Datenschuss ist eine sehr wichtige Sache, aber man muss das ein bisschen eingebettet sehen. Also ich würde sagen, wir brauchen gewisse verbraucherpolitische Anforderungen. Das heißt, wir müssen sicherstellen, dass sehr hohe Sicherheits dort herrscht in diesen Systemen. Wir müssen sicherstellen, dass die Leute, die mit diesen Systemen umgehen, dass die vertrauenswürdig sind. Weil sonst ist natürlich, wenn die Umgebung von diesen Systemen nicht vertrauenswürdig ist, auch die Systeme korrumpiert irgendwie. Wir müssen was erreichen, worüber wir noch wenig gesprochen haben, über die ausreichende Nutzerfreundlichkeit. Also muss die Sachen, wenn jetzt irgendwas gemessen wird, muss ich nicht so ganz hoch gucken, sondern das muss dann auf Augenhöhe eingestellt werden können und solche Sachen. Relativ einfach. Und wir brauchen sowas wie Sozialverträglichkeit. Also über die Überwindungssicherheit wird vielleicht Sabath noch was sagen. Zur Vertrauenswürdigkeit ganz kurz. Wir müssen auch schauen, dass wir zuverlässige und überprüfbare Evaluierungskriterien haben für diese Systeme. Das heißt, wir müssen das vergleichen können. Wir müssen das bewerten können. Und das können wir momentan nicht. Das heißt, es gibt noch keine richtigen Anbieter, unabhängigen Stellen, die das halt durchchecken. Es gibt wenige Tests, die gelaufen sind in diesem Bereich, aber noch ist zu viel von den Herstellern und deren Aussagen abhängig.
Und wenn die Tests gelaufen sind, dann mit so geringen Benutzerzahlen, dass eigentlich die Aussagen total irrelevant sind.
Das heißt, die Einzigen, die beurteilen können, ob das System okay ist, sind dann auch die wenigen, die das System wirklich selber rausbringen wahrscheinlich.
Die können es auch noch nicht mal, weil sie selber irgendwie die Tests nicht gemacht haben.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel bei bestimmten Sicherheitsmargen, wissen wir, dass wir mindestens 10.000, 15.000 Leute, man kann das ausrechnen, im Übrigen bezogen auf die Systeme, brauchen, um überhaupt einen validen Test zu bekommen.
Für Deutschland. Also man muss ja bedachten, dass man dann, wenn man solche Systeme entwickelt, auch Menschen aller Ethnien mit einbezieht zur Evaluierung. Das heißt, man braucht irgendwie asiatisch aussehende Leute, afrikanisch aussehende Leute, also Schwarze, weil einfach sonst die Systeme, wenn sie das erste Mal einen Asiaten sehen, irgendwie total nicht damit klarkommen werden und irgendwie die Leute dann halt nicht erkannt werden.
Ja, und wir haben ein zusätzliches Problem, dass der digitalen Spaltung mal in eine andere Richtung, ja, was machen wir denn bei der Exklusion? Muss dann ein Zwang zur Biometrie geben? Also, was passiert mit den Leuten, die halt schlicht keine Finger haben? Oder deren Gesicht so entsteht, dass ein Gesichtsbild zumindest mit den normalen Abmessungen den Verfahren keinen Sinn macht? Oder bei der Iris Probleme haben mit Augenkrankheiten?
Dazu braucht man dann immer ein zweites Merkmal oder irgendwie eine Alternative. Und dadurch, dass man diese Alternative braucht, sind eigentlich die ganzen Sicherheits- also die ganze Sicherheit wie der Adapzong geführt, weil halt einfach jener, der anreisen will und irgendwie sein Fingerabdruck irgendwo gespeichert ist, der brennt sich halt einfach die Fingerabdrücke weg und kommt dann halt trotzdem rein, weil halt seine Finger nicht mehr mit dem Täter-Fingerabdruck übereinstimmen.
Was kein Witz ist, in Schweden ist das bei Leuten, die Asyl beantragt haben, tatsächlich passiert. Die haben sich dann die Fingerkuppen verätzt oder halt verbrannt und zwar auch so tiefgehend, dass das nicht wieder nachwächst, um halt diese sozusagen, diese Tests zu umgehen.
Also so richtig böse, das muss irgendwie echt wehgetan. Ich hab mal irgendwie letztens einen Selbstversuch gemacht, hab versucht meinen Fingerabdruck runter zu polieren.
Oh Mann, stop.
Das ist angefangen zu bluten und die sind, also es hat immer noch, der Sensor hat die immer noch erkannt, das heißt, das muss bei denen echt wehgetan haben.
Ja, der Chaos Computer Club probiert solche Sachen tatsächlich aus. Was ist denn mit Ländern, also wir hatten vorhin über die USA gesprochen, dass die eben halt sowas nachholen, dass die dann Fingerabdrücke nehmen, wenn man da einreißt, und das Ganze nicht diesen biometrischen Anforderungen genügt. Was ist, wenn man aus einem Land kommt und man hat das nicht? Wird das dann hier in Deutschland auch passieren? Was machen die dann? Ich meine, die können einem ja nicht schnell an der Grenze einen Pass ausstellen, der dann diesen Lärm macht.
Nee, das nicht. Das, was vorgesehen ist, zum Beispiel, dass in den Ländern, wo die dann herkommen, wenn sie ein Visum brauchen, natürlich dann dort zu einer Behörde gehen müssen, die dann halt die biometrischen Merkmale erfassen, soweit vorhanden, und das dann halt hier hin zum Abgleich, zum Beispiel mit solchen Verhandlungsdateien oder Migrationsdateien, dann halt das vergleichen und dann sagen, okay, die können rein, können nicht rein. Also zum Beispiel. Solche Feldversuche gab es schon in LaROS zum Beispiel.
Werden diese ganzen Mehrkosten für dieses elektronische Spektakel eigentlich umgeschlagen auf den User?
Letztendlich zahlt alles der User.
Entweder ersteuert oder halt, also die Ausweise werden auf jeden Fall teurer werden. Also wenn man jetzt für einen Pass 10 Euro, wie viel auch immer bezahlt, dann sicherlich das Doppelte werden, allein weil die Chips halt...
Ja, das ist die Frage. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es da irgendwelche Aussagen von den Politikern schon gibt, ob das tatsächlich auf die Passgebühr sich umschlägt oder ob das einfach durch Steuern oder sonst was Querverfahren finanziert wird.
Ja, im Endeffekt spielt es aber keine Rolle. Also man kann die Zahlen von dem TAP-Bericht, das Büro für Technikfolgeabschätzung des Bundestags, mal anführen. Und sie haben für den kritischsten Fall, also dass wirklich komplett neue Ausweise generiert werden müssen, setzen sie Zahlen an von einmalig 600 Millionen für die Einführung und dann jährlich noch mal ungefähr 600 Millionen, die dann wirklich jedes Jahr anfallen, wenn dieses System betrieben werden soll.
Man muss sich das ja auch vorstellen, das ist ja ein ganz komplexes Ding. Wir haben ungefähr 6.500 Meldestellen, bei denen man dann bei der Mehrzahl auch sagen müsste, die müssen halt sozusagen die Möglichkeit haben, Leute in so ein biometrisches System einzubringen, also das in OneMet durchzuführen. Also wir haben hunderte, also 700, 800 Grenzkontrollpunkte, die dann auch mit ein oder mehreren Geräten ausgestattet werden. Und dann kommt mir ja noch dazu, wir müssen die Leute weiterbilden, die müssen geschult sein. Fürs Enrollment durchzuführen ist nicht so, dass man sagt, ok, pack doch da mal dann Finger drauf auf so ein Sensor, sondern da muss ja dann auch in einer bestimmten Art und Weise aufgelegt werden. Da muss man also kontrollen, ob das nicht mit zu viel Druck und solche Sachen. Also das ist eine relativ komplexe Geschichte.
Der Alex aus Osthessen. Na, Wendt, deine Meinung dazu?
Also ich bin eigentlich dagegen, aber es gibt ja auch Geschäftsmodelle, mit denen man das Ganze eigentlich theoretisch mit dem Auslesen der Ausweise per RFID und so weiter wunderbar für sich ausschlachten könnte. Also man stellt sich dann halt als irgendwas Würstchenverkäufer oder sonst an den Flughafen, wo die Leute alle ihre Reisepässe dabei haben sollten, bei den Flügen, die nicht innerhalb Deutschlands sind, und guckt halt hin, wo geht der Flieger hin, hat das dann, kann man sich ja notieren, liest dazu halt die Daten aus den Ausweisen aus, hat die Adressen und kann das denke ich mal an so Reiseveranstalter wunderbar weiterverkaufen.
Wie schwierig ist es denn ein Würstchenstand auf so einen Flughafen zu kriegen?
Also nicht Würstchenstand, sondern man läuft halt da drüber, spricht die Leute an, verteilt vielleicht Flyer oder so.
Da wirst du auch schon Schwierigkeiten bekommen, wenn du da am Flughafen einfach weiterverkaltest.
Dann stellt man sich halt vor dem Flughafen. Aber ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Idee. Also ich meine, das ist nicht auszuschließen. Wobei wir halt immer wieder darauf hinweisen müssen, dass nach derzeitigen Stand der Technik in Deutschland das nicht möglich sein sollte. Wir können auch nichts anderes sagen. Also die Politiker setzen da halt irgendwie immer neue Standards und was dann im Endeffekt wirklich bei rauskommt, werden wir sehen, wenn es da ist. Ich befürchte dich einfach mal.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall in anderen Ländern bzw. Amerika wird das auf jeden Fall ein Geschäftsmodell werden können. Kundenorientierte Werbung.
Ja, die kriegen wir jetzt ja schon. Aber es geht natürlich besser. Ich meine, auch da wieder so ein filmischer Vorschlag Kundenorientierte Werbung mit Iris. Da muss man sich mal Neutie-Reports angucken und da sieht man, wie das aussehen könnte. Takamoto oder irgendwie. Aber wir sind da schon sehr nahe bei der Sache dabei und beobachten das natürlich auch und versuchen dann Einwürfe einzubringen. Aber die Leistungsfähigkeit von solchen zivilgesellschaftlichen Gruppen, CCC, Füllboot oder solchen, die sind sehr begrenzt. Wir machen das in unserer Freizeit. Das muss man einfach sehen. Wir haben dann Gruppen wie Standardisierer, wo dann 20 Leute an diesen Standards arbeiten, nur in Deutschland.
Ach ja, da fällt mir gerade noch was ein. Der CCC hatte ja eine Presseerklärung abgegeben zu dieser Entscheidung bezüglich der jüngsten Entscheidung bezüglich Fingerabdrückungen in Ausweisdokumenten. Und da gab es dann eine Antwort des Sprechers des Bundesministeriums des Inneren, der dann meinte, der CCC soll doch bitte bei seinen Leisten bleiben und möge sich um die Hacker kümmern und nicht um die Sicherheit. Wenn ich denke, Hacker haben was mit der Sicherheit zu tun und es geht hier um digitale Sicherheit und Zertifikate und Chips und Infrastruktur und so weiter.
Da hat er einfach voll daneben geschossen. Es war echt peinlich. Vielleicht kurz nochmal, wo es gerade angesprochen wird, zu der Pressemeldung. Also ihr hattet ja einen technischen Hintergrund. Und zwar die Möglichkeit Fingerabdrücke zu kopieren. Das heißt, diese ganze Sicherheitssimulation ist einfach wirklich nur eine Simulation, weil man Fingerabdrücke kopieren kann, wie gesehen in Getica. Also es funktioniert wirklich. Man nimmt halt irgendwie einen Fingerabdruck von der Matheflasche oder liest ihn vielleicht direkt schön in ordentlicher Qualität aus dem Ausweis selber aus. Und kann ihn dann mit einfachsten Mitteln einfach auf eine Kopierfolie drucken und mit Holzleim irgendwie den trocknen lassen. Und dann klebt man sich die Attrappe, also praktisch die dünne Schicht auf dem Finger und hat irgendwie schwupps eine andere Identität. Also das heißt, man hat dann einen fremden Fingerabdruck und kann den benutzen.
Ja und besonders spannend wird das, wenn man das macht beim Enrollment. Dann kann man nämlich mit einem falschen Fingerabdruck einen echten, in Anführungszeichen, Ausweis, der dann auf diesen neuen Fingerabdruck funktioniert.
Das hatten wir doch auch schon mal, wo es dann darum ging, dass dann irgendwie ein Puls gemessen werden soll und dass man den simulieren kann, indem man mit der Hand immer drüber wedelt, weil das helle und dunkel wird und dass dann quasi den Puls simuliert, der eigentlich im Daumen ist.
Das zeigt halt einfach nur mal, dass die Systeme überhaupt noch gar nicht, also nicht mal annähernd wirklich einsatztechnisch, also einsatzreif für den Einsatz sind. Weil sie halten mit, also es war wirklich ein paar Stunden Aufwand und irgendwie minimalsten Geldmitteln, kann man dieses ganze System praktisch aushebeln. Wer dazu mehr wissen will, kann irgendwie mal auf www.cccde.de slash biometrie klicken. Da gibt es auch ein schickes Filmchen, wo das alles nochmal schön beschrieben wird. Und da stehen auch ganz wichtig unsere Forderungen zum Einsatz von Biometrie an die Innenminister bzw. an unsere Politiker allgemein. Die wichtigste ist einfach, dass Systemerfahre erwendet werden, die eine aktive Teilnahme der Person an der Überprüfung gewährleisten. Das heißt eigentlich sollten wir alle Gesichtserkennung zum Beispiel ablehnen, weil da die Gefahr besteht, dass Leute im Vorbeigehen praktisch identifiziert werden. Also wenn schon eine Identifikation stattfinden soll, dann soll der Benutzer auch aktiv daran beteiligt sein. Er muss zustimmen, dass er jetzt identifiziert werden will. Das ist praktisch die Grundforderung.
Und für den Fall, dass etwaige Mitarbeiter von Herrn Schili mithören, die jetzt wieder in sich hineinflüsten, dass wir bei unseren Leisten bleiben sollen. Herr Schili hat ja selber auch mal so schön gesagt, man muss sich halt weiterentwickeln. Und als Letzter wahrscheinlich in der Runde der Richard nochmal. Richard.
Hallihallo, hier ist der Richard. Ich war auch euer erster Anrufer heute.
Wahnsinn, was für eine Klammer.
Perfektes Timing. Ich habe jetzt inzwischen dieses Verständlichkeitsproblem gelöst, indem ich mir Kopfhörer besorgt habe. Da kann ich also meine Anlage aufdrehen und auch nicht über die Ohrmuschel des Telefonhörers nicht zu verstehen. Ja, was ich noch sagen wollte als Abschluss, und zwar die Lösung des Ganzen, und zwar die Lösung eurer Probleme, die ihr alle gerade angesprochen habt.
Ja, 42.
Nee, 23.
Ewige Flumenkraft.
Gut, die Lösung eurer Probleme, die ihr meist technischerseits verursacht, ist, kleine bio-organische Chips den Menschen einfach per Spritze, im Funk einzupflanzen, die sich dann im System des Menschen, des organischen Körpers integrieren, die auch 99,999% nicht wieder zu entfernen sind, den Menschen einzupflanzen, die den einfach identifizieren können. Das wird bereits seit mehreren Jahren, gibt es Experimente und Tests dazu, im Tierbereich.
Tolle Lösung, die Lösung, die wir noch nie haben wollten.
Ja, es gibt ohne, also ganz ernsthaft, gibt es schon seit mehreren Jahren eine Erforschung in der Richtung und es gibt sehr viele Beispiele, wo das bei Tieren gemacht wird.
In Amerika wurden irgendwie auch gerade die erste Familie damit ausgestattet, also es wird auch schon bei Männchen gemacht. Ja, genau, super.
Und ermauert das ja. Ja, und ich denke mal, die Taktik ist die, man fängt bei den Tieren an, zum Beispiel mit Argumenten wie, wenn ihr Tier ihnen davonläuft, kann man es wiederfinden und identifizieren. Also das passiert dann auch bei einer Leiche, man muss dann auch wahrscheinlich nicht aktiv sein, man kann jeden identifizieren. Es wird sehr viele Argumente dann dafür geben, den Menschen das zu verkaufen und dass sie das annehmen. Und die Akzeptanz der Bevölkerung wird dann einfach auch zustimmen. Und damit haben wir wieder unser totalitäres Kontrollsystem.
Tja, dann muss mir wohl was dagegen tun. Wir fangen hiermit jetzt an und jeder, der zuhört, fängt morgen aus und wird irgendwie auch was dagegen tun.
In der Bibel, in der Apokalypse steht dazu ein Bericht über diese Geschichte.
Ein Nachbericht, sozusagen.
Wir wissen, wie es endet.
Ja, wir wissen auch, wie es endet, genau. Wer das wissen will, weiß es. Ja, und zwar steht da drin, dass jeder, der sich an dem System nicht beteiligen wird, quasi gesellschaftlich...
In die Hölle kommt.
Nee, nicht mehr existieren werden kann in dem System. Das System wird zerstört nach drei Jahren. Aber es wird zum Beispiel nicht mehr möglich sein, das System zu kaufen oder zu verkaufen. Also es wird dann so weit gehen, dass auch die ganzen Bankentransfer- und Geldgeschäfte einfach nur noch per Identifikation laufen.
Ja gut, aber Richard, das ist ja sowieso schon so. Ich meine, du kommst ja ohne Konto sowieso nicht mehr weit und wenn du irgendwie nicht gesellschaftsfähig bist, kriegst du kein Konto. Also die Spanner haben wir schon. Ist aber auch wieder ein anderes Thema. Danke dir für den Anruf, weil wir sind am Ende von der Zeit. Tschüss. Ach, ich ja, Mensch, in einer Literarische, da blühe ich ja sofort auf. Ich hab neulich wieder gelesen, Dante's Inferno, da waren diese ganzen Ketzer-Sorten. Da ging es darum, dass bestimmte Arten von Ketzern und der weiß Ketzer irgendwie Ehebetrüger, da passiert ja mit allem was anderes. Ich glaube, die Ketzer wurden in Särge aus kochendem Blei gesteckt und so.
Super.
Der feinste Horrorfilm. Vielleicht können wir zum Schluss noch mal, oder kurz vor Schluss noch mal auf die Mailing-Liste, auf die Mail-Adresse dieser Sendung hinweisen, und zwar ist das 97 at chaosradio.ccc.de also 97 at chaosradio.ccc.de und für die Links, die wir uns hier gesagt haben, oder uns gesagt wurden, gibt es dann auch chaosradio.ccc.de als Webseite. Zum später noch mal draufklicken.
Ja, und da findet ihr dann auch Hinweise für Dokumente, wo man Sachen nachlesen kann. Nicht vollständig, klar, weil es gibt auch einiges an Texten, aber so wichtige zentrale Texte, die werden wir dann schon da verfügen können.
Und die ganzen e-Caos-Pics. Und vor allen Dingen sind auch Ansprechpartner darauf, wie man mal eine Mail schreiben kann, um so ein gewisses Lobby zu sein, die man auch sein sollte bei dem Thema. Also, dass man einfach auch Leute ein bisschen Backbone gibt, die genau das versuchen durchzusetzen in Brüssel und dass da auch die Leute stehen, die Ansprechpartner.
Und ihr könnt uns also sozusagen, die ganzen Bürgerrechts- und Vereine, die sind auch einsprechbar für dieses Thema. Also, ihr könnt auch Mail schicken an CCC, an FöBoot, alles, was man da so bekommen kann. Wir werden euch da noch Hinweise dazu packen.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank auch fürs zahlreiche Mitmachen bei der Sendung, beim Chaosradio. Es wird wieder eins geben im... Ach so, kommt ja erst im November jetzt. Im November kommt noch mal eins. Im Dezember ist ja traditionellerweise keins. Aber im November wird auch wieder ein Chaosradio stattfinden. Wir verabschieden uns, freuen uns aufs nächste Mal. Unsere Namen...
Peter Fittner.
Ich bin Starwag.
Und Harald.
Und der Max. Ich sag Tschüss, macht's gut.